They have different that I'm learning
in between when I do comedy and acting.
Is that like the last thing people really
want to see from the on your own stage
as you really get emotional,
you know, but when you asked,
you have to go to that
right away. Big Difference.
We're live. Is it working?
Oh my Jesus. Right at the
end of the candid moment. No,
I think you're totally right.
Well,
Ron Funches and I were talking about
people getting mad. First of all,
welcome to the show strength
or having me being here, man.
I'm pretty sure we were talking about
people getting getting emotional on stage.
If people get angry on stage that um,
it shows the audience can feel it. You
could say the exact same words and with,
with like a fake anger as we were saying,
like Brody was really good at like he had,
he would fake be mad at you.
I mean, it was, it was Louis Black. Yes.
If you could see those exact same words,
there's like a smile to it,
right?
You were saying that there's
a nod or a hint hint of a nod.
Yeah, there's a little wink that lets
you know that this isn't, this is a joke,
I'm not really this mad about it.
And is it usually an absurdity
about the thing they're mad at? Yes.
You know when you get,
we all see those sets sometimes when
like someone's recently broken up with
somebody and then you like,
you get that real anger and then you
could say something funny but like,
it's too fresh.
It's too real,
don't want heritage, want to hear
it makes them feel uncomfortable.
And we were talking about
how weird it is the,
that you could actually have something
that sounded so similar to that,
but we could tell the difference, like
with the exact same words, you know,
with enthusiasm, just something's off
about it. Something's off about that,
you know, it's funny versus something's
off about it where you know,
that person's serious
and a person like I was,
we were just saying try to explain
that to someone who doesn't understand
English or doesn't understand human
communication. They'd be like, what?
How can you tell? Like, how can you tell
it's fake? How can you tell us fake anger?
Yeah, that's what mates, I
mean the language, so fun.
It's not just about the words,
it's about the intent behind the word.
Yes.
And body language and posture
and make a comedy so deep.
You know, I love about it. Oh
for sure. Yeah. I mean there,
what we're trying to do is convey intent
or trying to figure out a way to sneak
ideas into your head where maybe you
didn't see the punchline. Common. Yeah.
It's a, it's a very strange art
form. Like one of the strangest ever.
So cause it's, uh, I've, I've always said
it's almost like a form of mass hypnosis.
Do you feel that sometimes,
like can your middle of the sat and you,
you're in the groove? Yeah.
Um, a lot of ways. Um,
one of 'em
I mean you,
and you're a weird guy so it doesn't
matter what it's going to get weird in
multiple ways. But um, when I
first started my acting class, um,
I was talking about that, what, what,
what my acting coach. And I'd be like,
there's a point like if my sets really
going well where I'm in the present
moment of enjoying the set and saying
these words, but at the same time I'm,
I'm in the future thinking
about what's coming next.
I'm surveying everything that's going
around me and I'm also still kind of like
judging myself off of what just happened.
So this thing happens where you're kind
of like time traveling in a way where
you don't exist in any one space of time.
You,
you just kind of like
remove yourself from that.
And when your sets going really well,
that's the thing that my girlfriend and
I have talked about is that you can hear
these sets and hear these jokes. Maybe
you can see someone said multiple time,
but they're really good.
Oftentimes you don't remember the joke
like how many times people go back and
quote a joke to you and they've got it
half wrong because they've heard you with
a thousand times,
but they don't know they got the joke
half wrong because you've hypnotized them.
They don't even remember it,
you know?
Yeah. Or some people remember shit.
You don't remember anymore. Yeah,
that's a weird one. Yeah. I've had people
come up to me and tell me a bit, I go,
what? What bid is that? And
they'll tell me the bit, I'm like,
when is that from the 2014 I'm like,
I don't even remember that.
Yeah, just something you were
trying out. Every now knows.
That's what's fun now for
me as I'm getting a little
bit deeper than I'm coming
up on 13 years is now,
now I'm getting the point where I'm like,
Oh this bit that I tried two
or three years ago now work.
Yes. Yeah. That's really fun. Yeah,
I remember that that time you are,
you're essentially a a phd in
comedy when you got 10 years in.
Like if you have do real 10 hard years
of comedy and then after that it seems
like some, some guys, I mean it
all depends on the artist, right?
But some guys have their best work like
1516 years in or just starting to catch
the groove and figure out what
it is. You know, cause it's a,
it's only understood by the
people who practice it. It's,
it's understood in a way by
a lot of people who are, um,
comedy fans.
But that's similar to like
me being a fan of music.
I don't know shit about music, but I know
what I like. I know when it sounds good.
Yeah.
I literally don't understand any of it.
So I think there's those
kinds of people too.
Yeah. I mean comedy is such a, yeah,
I mean that's where gives great.
When your peers,
what's one thing that I loved about
doing my special other than like people
seeing it and being able to like I
wanted to just make something and put
something out.
I had always done like small little
things or guested on people's things and I
was like, oh, I'm been doing comedy over
10 years and I'm sure a lot of potential.
I want to present a male.
And when I put it out and like people's
reaction was great but the but my peers
is what really made me happy
that when I would get texts from,
from like Malanie or time,
some people being like you are or
just be like this was your hour,
this is you presenting who you are
completely right and that and that. Um,
when people can see the stuff behind it,
when it's not just like joke, punchline,
joke, punchline. When people can
see like, oh you set this up,
you did this rag, your structure is
right and then you just wear yourself.
That's what really makes
me happy in comedy.
Yeah. Yeah. You're a funny
dude man. I enjoy watching.
You have washed to quite a few times
the comedy store now in the main room.
You very,
very funny man.
It's cool to see a guy
like you put something down
that's representative of your
real, your real stand up,
what you're capable of doing.
It's a nice group to be a part of man.
And you sound like you think about
it a lot. I really appreciate that.
When people think about like what
it is we're doing, how do you do it?
How do you do it? Like, do you
write, do you write on paper?
Do you write with a typewriter?
Do you just write,
just have ideas and you
just keep working on them?
It's all a mix. You know,
I like to say like I'm a,
I'm more of a Fisher than a hunter.
Like I'm not constantly like, oh,
I need to write his down every day.
I have the structure,
but I'm constantly like,
I try to make my house that we're,
we're constantly always
joking around with each other.
There's notebooks everywhere.
There's like little bowls of like
with post it notes for me, whenever I,
an idea comes,
I had to make sure I catch it and then
I had to make sure that I work on it,
you know? Um, that becomes a different,
it's just constantly keeping myself
in motion so that I don't, um,
get stagnant and I don't just do the same
10, 15 over and over again that cause,
you know, that's where I think especially,
um, when I first moved out here,
it was always about like, oh, I got
to show these people that I'm good,
so I got to do my best work,
my best work.
And I did that for about three
months and I was like, oh,
I don't have anything in the kitchen.
I don't have any backup. You know,
I haven't been building anything up.
And so I learned very quickly,
I think the comedy store has been the
best for me or that it just being like I'm
having to like follow people who are
completely not like me stylistically.
Um, having to follow people who
I grew up watching. You know,
I did a, um, night the other
day where I had to follow,
it was Sebastian and then Ron Wyatt
and then me. And then I was like, oh,
there's no, I mean, I'm like, ah, I'm
confident in myself when people know me.
But when it comes to that,
it's like I'm the bottom of the totem
pole on those three and I had to go out
there and just show them that like,
I'm capable.
I'm not going to mess up the momentum
here. I'm just as funny as these people.
You just don't know me.
You haven't met me yet.
That's the thing I've been listening to
a lot. Like there's rappers all the time,
but like this rapper, two
Chainz where he said like, um,
I just had to wait for,
for the fans and for the game
to learn what I already knew.
And that's where I'm starting
to feel now a new confidence.
If like I know I'm good and I just have
to wait for people to catch up on my
wave and I don't. If they
don't, they don't. If they do
find just very jazz of you.
Two Chainz
was the guy who debated Nancy grace about
weed or remember that weight is going
to kill you.
He outlasted her.
Yeah. That didn't work. I mean,
it's hilarious now and see how many states
have legalized it. In full disclosure,
Ron and I smoked marijuana with
young Jamie before this podcast.
I guess weight as I do so many others.
It's finally the stigmas slowly
being removed slowly. Dude,
I was a drug addict in the
90s when I started, when I
first started smoking weed,
I guess it was a not even the
nineties it was like, wow,
that was a nightmare in 98
or 99 somewhere around that.
It's when I started smoking weed and uh,
you were a drug addict.
You were a drug addict. You're a
marijuana user. It's wrong with you, man.
Get your shit together. I'm like, man,
you guys don't get it. There's two chains.
There he is. Nancy grace. They put the
stuff on the screen when it was going on.
How many marijuana is
does it take to overdose?
Jamie, send me that. Send me that.
That is a fucking amazing quote.
Did she really say that?
No, no, no. It's a Twitter user. They
put, people were tweeting whatever.
Hashtag pot to blame. Oh my God. The
Twitter, the Twitter user. Oh, styler.
Tyler 2015 it says, oh
Tyler. 2015 dude that,
but it's 2015 the day of the tweet. It
must be nice probably just as an account,
but I don't know when it happens.
It's a weird time dealt with is a space
in there so that don't well, yeah,
I think 2015 well whether,
I dunno, I dunno. Yeah,
whoever's, whoever that
is, congratulations. Made
me laugh my ass off. Yeah.
That's funny. But yeah, that's what I love
is a ridiculous lady. You know, she's,
she obviously wasn't that healthy,
you know, she wasn't, uh, a very, uh,
fit health conscious person
just worrying about weed.
She's a crazy person. She was like
Paula Dean, but she couldn't cook food.
Marijuana, Moon. It's going to
kill you. Rolling Fund chills.
People still like that.
There's a lot of people like
that in the middle of the country
and then the middle of the country,
sometimes it's still like, you know,
there's the last thing might
have been racially, you know,
depends on they get the soccer we'd moms
and everybody was like, oh, that's cool.
And then you still get that.
Like I did a podcast the other day
and the first comments were like,
either your years, two stones
you're not doing. I was like, no,
I just did a bad job. You know, like
I could have just done a bad job.
It didn't have any they they
need to do with me being in stone.
Yeah.
Like they know that if you were sober
the podcast would have been way better.
Yeah. You were sober man. You would
have been so weird. It's true.
It's all true. I used to have to go to
this place to Inglewood wellness center,
so it was kind of in a hood
area. Um, a little bit sketchy.
And then a while we're going there,
like within a year or two later,
the guy who ran it got
shot and robbed there.
That's how dangerous weed was.
Cause he had to do it all in cash.
They wouldn't let banks use checks,
it wouldn't know,
wouldn't accept checks and credit cards.
So everything was weird.
Even though it was
medical and it was legal.
You had to get it through nefarious ways.
And then slowly but surely
the stigma started to erase.
Yeah.
Now you can just go to a store on Melrose.
Yes. So like what, how do you feel,
you're wise man?
How do you feel I should have qualified?
That felt like neat.
I'm setting you up.
What do you think about
making all drugs legal?
Do you think that that would ever happen?
And given what we know about prohibition,
it sounds like an interview,
given what we know about prohibition,
like how bad it was for alcohol
and how it popped up, the, uh,
organized crime and I mean
it caused a lot of problems.
Do you think it would be a wise
thing to make all drugs legal?
That's a tough question
for me. I think that's, um,
I think you have to start,
I guess that's really trying to give
people a lot of credit about their
intelligence and their decision making.
Right.
And that's what you're trying
to lead towards, that the,
that the individual was
very intelligent and they,
they're gonna make their
decision no matter what.
And that by putting these stigmas who
are just like, you know, like you know,
prostitution and things like that, your
PR, you're just adding extra jail time,
extra obstacles, extra, um,
life threatening situation.
And you're also penalizing people for
their own life choices instead of propping
up organized crime or as well as where
they're pro propping up organized crime.
And if you've seen the effects of drug
addiction, which I've had on occasion,
you is hard to go like,
yeah, this should it be okay.
You know, I 100% agree. So
it's, it's not that clean.
No, I don't, they
didn't. That's why. Yeah,
that will be my answer is I
don't think it's that clean.
I think that it is a case by case basis.
We'll do I think marijuana
should be legal. I absolutely do.
I think that you should necessarily
legalize heroin. No, I don't think so.
I don't think so either.
Um, but I think that,
I think there's a real problem
with infants realizing adults.
The,
the real problem is like if you are 25
years old or older and you decide you
want to try cocaine, whose, whose, why,
why can they say you can't do that?
Why says who? So the
zoo, why is that? Why,
why have you catch me with that?
Can you put me in a jail?
It grows from the ground. It's a plant.
They take that plant, they process it.
They turned to cocaine.
They still use it legally for,
of and medical grade cocaine.
They still use it for
the flavor of Coca Cola.
They still use the leaves.
They still use the plant.
Like who says I don't even do coke.
But who the fuck do you think
is making money selling coke?
Cause there's a lot of coke.
It's one thing that's completely
why Miami exists. It's very,
no, it did. No other industry in
Miami and there's so much money there.
Did you see cocaine cowboys? Mm, no dude.
Billy Corbin, the guy who directed it
was on the podcast yesterday. He's a,
he's fantastic and he's got this new
book, um, documentary called screw ball.
It's about Alex Hernandez and steroids.
In baseball and all this crazy shit. Oh,
Brian Rodriguez, who's actioning does
this is a different one. Hey Rod.
How I say he is that
guy? No, that's Aaron.
That's new England patriot.
Scott. Dan Weeds. Fuck my head up.
That is the guy from the Patriots.
Aaron Hernandez. Oh, okay. That's why
I fucked it up. My apologies. Alex.
Alex Rodriguez and uh, anyway, this,
this guy made a documentary called cocaine
cowboys and it's all about how crazy
during the big cocaine days
Miami was and how one year,
the entire graduating class of the
sheriff's Academy, the Police Academy,
whatever it was,
they either were murdered or they
were arrested for corruption.
The whole, everyone, the entire class,
like the entire graduating year,
like every,
it was wild west chaos and there was
all these pilots bringing in millions of
dollars worth of coke and they had
bags of money buried in their backyard.
It's fucking crazy ass. Interesting.
It's great, man. It's great.
It's a two part series or it
says there's two parts to it too.
Do you ever do versus Black Mafia family?
You ever,
you ever watch any documentaries about
them? That makes me always interested.
What did they do?
They were a,
a cocaine outlet and the early two
thousands out of Atlanta and they transmit
that at one point they were running and
like most of the south southeast, um,
head by this dude named big Meech.
And um,
then they decided like we should
legalize and get into a rap,
but they had never done anything like
that before and they were very blatant
about it. So the, all of a sudden these
people who were came out of nowhere,
we're just all on like
every magazine. The, um,
they have this thing where
they're introduced interviewing
police officers and
they had this big billboard when
you inland it Atlanta that would go,
that would just say BMF,
we own the world.
And they were just out there and they
would throw these big parties with tigers
and stuff and they only had one
recording artists. So it was just like,
they weren't good at pretending
not to be drug dealers. Wow.
So it's very interesting you're saying
to me, well that whole,
um, ramp businessman,
I mean if you just stop and think about
rap music other than some country and I
mean really like a small amount of
country would talk about murder and men.
You know,
I shot a man in Reno just to
watch him and a few Johnny Cash,
maybe some Merle haggard, Waylon
Jennings, maybe some, some of those songs.
But when you get to like Nwa,
you have a different level
of aggression. You know, when you
get to a [inaudible] body count,
when he was doing that hard metal shed
new soon fuck the police or uh, uh, um,
I'm a cop killer. I mean, it's either Nwa
fuck the police or ice teas. I'm a cop.
Koeuch you hear those? Like you'd never
heard of anything like that before.
Yeah, though the interest in time, because
that's, I mean, talking about real anger,
when we talked about before,
this is all coming from real places
and people who were Dylan Wa,
you know, Los Angeles at a horrible
time in, in La police corruption.
And then what's crazy is in you,
it goes the other way, right?
They take that real anger that people
connect it to and then they just started
manufacturing it and then wrap becomes
all these fake stories of like,
I murdered all these people. I
have all this money and, and,
and then now it's just so far gone
that it, it, it's hard to find.
I mean now my favorite authentic rap is
like people who are like, Oh, you know,
I can't find my wifi password or
are people just talking about raising
their kids now I love that and rap cause
then I'm like, oh, you're for real.
Yeah. Why not talk about anything.
You know, today was a good day,
right? I mean that was like one
of the original ones, right?
They used to be a song called
all you could eat, which
was Joe about go into off.
But like today was a good day.
I mean is that is like a classic example
of someone taking the art form and
completely switching it up and slowing
it down and make it casual and relaxed
and celebrate Tori.
And that's from the same dude.
Same Dude from Nwa. Nan
Smart Man, smart man.
He's a wizard of a writer to is,
his lyrics are fantastic.
You know there's like when there's lyrics
in my mind when it comes to hip hop,
there's lyrics and there's Nas.
Nas does shit that you just go
like that backwards song, you know,
he's just call it cause like
everything is. So it's like a,
like a practice like orchestra,
you know,
as opposed to just being rhymes. Like
it's sometimes he puts things together.
So, so interestingly, you know,
he's got his own special sort
of appreciation for things.
Yeah. He's also very smart man. He has
to be, he was the one that he won best.
He invests a lot of tech companies.
He does a lot of, he's begging
the investments.
Why is young twenties when he wrote that?
He's like 23 when that song came out.
That's incredible.
His Dad was like a jazz musician.
So I think he grew up around the culture
of creating things and being an artist.
He's got that feel to him.
He's like a hybrid, you know,
in terms of it's like jazzy rap sort of.
You know what I mean?
Like there's something to,
it was like almost like a
classical trained musician slash.
Rapper in terms of like how he
constructs things. Yeah. Like Hamilton.
I didn't see Hamilton.
Did you see it?
No, I am but allow people once
anything where a lot of light
that mayfly, why people get into a
rap. I go, they probably not for me.
Oh, I want to know any
rap about the presidents.
This one thing that like white guys have
managed to infiltrate certain elements
of,
but like it's such a small number of
like legitimately respected white rappers
was a number M and. M of
course. Yeah, for sure.
Kid Rock in a way.
He's kind of a rapper even though he,
does she respect the rapper?
No, no, no. But it's fun.
Yeah. It's excepted. Mc Sir
Macklemore Mc Mc search was great.
I used to love them. I used to
love third base. There were fun.
Everlast BC boy Everlast for sure,
but Everlast has changed
and now wraps occasionally.
I would think he would call himself
more of a musician now. Jump around.
He's still jumping around. Still
jump around. Well, not only that,
the last shit that they put out was
great to let stuff that he came in and
showed us and he did some stuff
with be real and some other guys.
What do they call it?
What was his last project?
Shout out to that project. We'll find
it. Jamie would find it. He's a shit,
but like a
or porn industry.
That's right. War Porn Industry's.
That's preposterous. Crazy name. Oh, hi.
Do you have to be to come up with that
name? Action Bronson. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Albanian. Oh, Action Bronson. Yeah, dude,
I've never seen a man smoke more
weed in my life. It never seen it.
He just keeps going like
he just ha hey man, look,
we took a picture of the ash tray after
it was over show all the, all the, uh,
expired blunt, but I was like, this is,
he's from that fuck. That's delicious.
Show you ever watch that. I'm a big
action prompts and fan. Do you allow them?
He's so interesting to me. Do you watch
the cooking show? Sometimes. Yeah.
It's interesting, right? Like that that
guy was a like a legit chef. Yeah. Yeah.
And Matt and then just that.
He's a great rapper.
Great Chef. A great personality.
Super Nice guy selling paintings now.
Good for him. Sell it for $1 billion.
That's $1 billion. You fucks.
That's 2 billion.
That's amazing.
That's a rug where a lot of weed bearings
on it. Get that money. Action Bronson.
Get that money. Yeah, man. I'm all for
people selling the most ridiculous shit.
I went to my agent's house once.
He had this dope place in Aspen.
I mean this place was
crazy. Like, you know,
Aspen houses like near the ski lodges
and Shit and on the wall he had this
painting and I said, I go,
did this kid make this? And
they go, no, that's a little,
you know, some fucking obscure
popular artists. I go, what is that?
And they like, this is a really
expensive piece of shut the fuck up.
You're messing with me. They're
like, no. It was like tissue paper.
There was like different colors.
It was stuck with glue and look a little
piece of paper and some paint on it and
like, get the fuck Outta
here with this. Like,
what are you doing with that cannon
camera? I mean, what the parade? No,
no, that's why I was stunned. I thought it
was his kid. I thought this kid made it.
Maybe I'm, maybe I'm just
dumb by definitely was, but
a younger and dumber, maybe.
I'd appreciate it now, but I
don't think so. I appreciate, uh,
all kinds of art.
I appreciate distorted things,
but I don't appreciate like just a bunch
of Splat, you know what I mean? Look,
it's gotta have something to it.
Like Jackson Pollock,
stuff like that stuff weirds me out. I
was like, why is it so expensive? Like,
I get it. I got it. You mean it's
crazy. It's definitely crazy.
But then you look at, you
know, you look a classic like,
uh, look at, uh, you know, some frank
Frazetta stuff. Do you know who that guy,
he was a, a fantasy painter homie from
the 19th. There's a poster of his,
or I'm a print of one of his works out
in the lobby that Conan the barbarian one
with that, uh, that monster it,
he's got a sword. He was, uh,
this guy that do, he would do all the
covers for Conan the barbarian books,
just incredible artwork, like
wild, crazy fantasy shit.
And this is your type of art. Oh,
just, I loved it when I was a kid, man,
when I was a kid. You
know, when I was a young,
this seems like what you would
like. I loved it. It was the best.
His books are incredible.
There's Robert Howard was this
really tortured guy who was, um,
a guy who lived with his
mom. He had, you know,
fairly poor health and he died
suicide when he was like 36 years old.
But he wrote a bunch of these books
about a guy that was nothing like him.
They've got a guy who was this just
unstoppable force of nature from this.
He created this place called, uh, was
Sumeria. We know what going to call it.
What was his Samarian? It was Samarian.
Is that what it was? We're Kona,
Kona in the Sumerian,
right.
See [inaudible] created a whole
world and in this world there's like,
it was like very games of throne.
He in a lot of ways,
the original shit like no one to this
day is really captured the books in a
movie.
Like Arnold was fun as Conan and then
Jason Momoa was like a better fit
physically.
He was like a perfect fit.
Physically more realistic as
opposed to like being a bodybuilder.
But nobody's ever captured like the
feeling of the books because the books is
just some wild shit.
And it was all created by this
one guy was like super depressed.
They're just write these books about
this guy who just fucked all these women
and killed everyone and just we'll just
smashed his way through the world and
power fan and things
like crazy shit though.
It was all him fighting
dragons and monsters and
demons coming for his soul and
he ran for 72 hours and
fight them off with a sword.
And this would just quit when you're 12
years old like I was and I got into this
shit. He'd be like, Whoa, this
is why I get that as like,
well ECW wrath was from me cause they
was like titties everywhere and violence
and blood and nails. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cause I watched one
yesterday on Instagram.
Somebody had a clip of a guy and a girl
and they're in the middle of the rain,
the guys making out with the girl and
then it turns on their body slams are down
to the ground. And I was like, well you
could still do that and pro wrestling,
you could still fake like fake violence
against a check. I didn't know. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Energetic arrest still. They
obey. They slam, they fake slam chicks.
That is crazy. I saw him do that. I was
like, that could not have felt good.
I lady stuck a blow pop up a
dude's butt recently. Oh No, he,
he didn't want it.
What is this about his deck?
He carried when you carry around
blow pop, I guess, you know. Wow.
Jesus Christ. Just Rathlin. Well,
whatever you got to do
to sell them tickets.
What is this Jeremy? This is the
blow pop thing. No Way. Oh my God.
He's really sticking it
up his ass in his mouth.
Oh my God.
And then decide ticks him in the face
and the guy's got his pants down.
Wait a minute. That might be the
greatest video I've ever seen in my life.
The same guy who did the like
the, you hit the deck. Shari.
Right? This beached great white
shark. That's crazy. Fuck.
That's crazy. I can't show it. The
shark was chasing a seagull. Oh,
you can't show it and accidentally
ended up in the beach.
Why don't these guys grab
it and pull it back in?
The fucking matter man is watching you.
Oh my God.
The guy's throwing water on it.
Just grab it. You just grab it.
They don't know. Oh, how do they
not know that's dead? It's dead now.
They can only last outside. Oh, it's
still still breathing a little bit.
That is crazy. That is an
ancient fucking feeding machine.
Look at the face on that thing,
man.
Just stop and think about what a
mother fucking nightmare the ocean is.
What a nightmare. Things like that. It
just roaming around and US assholes.
We think of being spiritual. Hey Man,
I'm just going to get out of my board.
I'm just going to get on my
board, be monster food. No,
I put my foot in the back out.
I'm such a pussy when it
comes to the ocean. I was in
Hawaii, we went snorkeling,
dive with the water and you staring down
and it was cool. We were by this reef,
but all I was thinking is I just need
one of these motherfuckers and I'm never
getting in this water again.
One of those motherfuckers.
I kind of want to do that now.
I couldn't,
I was too heavy before I was past the
weight limit that you could go do some
dive in.
Did you and I would always tell myself
I didn't want to do it by not want to do
that. Yeah. You could tell yourself
a lot of things, right? Yeah.
Mitch Michener a joke
about a writing that, uh,
when he gets the wrong idea,
he writes things down or
if he's lazy, he, yeah.
Not that funny.
How did you lose the weight?
Um,
I really just change them.
I got a trainer that was a big part of
it and just changed my diet and, um,
started exercising budget.
Went from a guy who didn't exercise
it all an eight multiple Philly cheese
steaks a day to a guy who eats a bunch
of boneless skinless chicken breast and
protein shakes. And now I work out
like six times a day. Wow. Yeah.
Just seemed like I was
going to die if I did.
So what do you do for
working out these days?
Uh, you know, low weight lifting, a lot
of 'em I don't see the day to, you know,
just love back a little,
a little biceps, you know,
one arm rolls and whatnot.
Just general weightlifting.
So, but you're, you do it a lot.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you, um,
do you find has an effect on your mood on
how you feel? Oh, absolutely. How do you,
how much better do you feel and how much
do you attribute it to the working out,
the losing weight or both of them
gathering? It's a combination,
definitely the, um, the Diet and,
and just feeling better nutrition wise is,
it is very helpful.
Um, but you know, just doing
two shows a night now, you know,
they used to be a thing for me.
I used to be like really tired
afterwards and now, you know, no problem.
I do a lot of um,
voiceovers and,
and other little things. And so, you know,
I'm always bouncing around from going
like doing shows in the weekend.
They'd come home and then having to go
do voiceover on Monday morning and taking
care of my son and helping him with his
homework and just being able to do that
and not being like, oh, I'm just, I got
to go pass out. I'm tired. You know?
That's the really the,
the biggest deal.
Being able to take on more so than
I'm able to, um, make more money.
So I was carrying my daughter
around my shoulders the other day.
She likes to get carried
around. She's 63 pounds and, uh,
while she's on my shoulders, uh, after,
you know, 40 minutes or so of that,
like it's fucking rough.
Like it starts really hurting your neck,
start getting really tired. And I had to
put her down and uh, I was thinking like,
how crazy is that though?
There's a lot of people that just carry
that much extra around with them all the
time.
They're always carrying around an extra
60 pounds and you don't think it's that
much of a deal until you don't have it
and then you walk with it. Yeah. You know,
and you realize like, and it's
this like, even if it's not that,
like when a kid sitting on your neck,
it's not like the ideal place to carry
all the weight. They actually make a, um,
a thing.
There's a company called the outdoorsman.
They make a thing called the atlas pack.
It's like a backpack frame.
But at the back of it is like one of
those weightlifting posts so you could
slide in Olympic a barbell or a
Olympic played on and two plates.
You put as much as 90 pounds on it,
clamp this thing down and then
it's sitting more on your hips.
It's way easier to carry,
but even that still it's fuck,
it's fucking man walking around
with just 45 extra pounds on your back.
Sucks.
Yeah, just getting, you know, just being
like my mid thirties and being like,
oh man, my knees are hurting. I
didn't, I never played football.
I never did anything like that.
My knees shouldn't be hurting and,
and just knowing,
I think I had to just change a,
just changed my mindset about like before
when I was just doing stand up to do
it and didn't think I was going to
be successful, it didn't matter.
I was just like, I'm this living Verdad
Day gimme free pizza, give me whatever.
And then I was like, once this things
started changing a little bit, I was like,
oh, I'm, things are happening. I still
don't even really know what I'm doing.
Let me, if I give myself a better
chance and take care of my health,
take care of my body, um, let me
see how far I can push these gift,
pushed these skills,
you know,
and it became more about not
wanting to waste the opportunity.
That's very cool. That's
cool. I liked that.
So your love of standup made you sort of
concentrate even more on your own body.
Yeah. That crazy. Yeah. Like
not your love of yourself,
not your love of your body.
Like of course like this is,
you have to go through number
of what you do in your life.
You're going through it with your body,
but it was your love of
stand up to me like, God,
I gotta do something about this
fucking body. Yeah. That crazy.
Yeah. Low stand up alone, my son and
we'll love of fashion and I didn't,
you know, when you get to
certain size all your shares,
good dogs on them and you know,
I want that anymore.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. It gets you
getting to that triple XL. I,
I'm happy whenever anybody does anything
that, uh, that benefits their health,
whether it's a for whatever your
motivation, the end result is always good.
It's always good no matter what
motivations, positive or negative.
If you want to prove somebody wrong,
you know, or you just want to do,
just do better. Just have a
better path, you know? So it's so,
it's so attainable for so many people.
So many people could at
least be way healthier.
At least have way more
energy at least like that.
Not that feeling of just
being like, Ugh, all day.
And every time I cheat like a
with burgers and fries and, and,
and like milkshakes and shit like that.
If I really go off the deep end
with my diet, I feel like dog shit,
I feel terrible. It hits me. I'm like, oh.
And then you've got to realize,
hey man,
this is how a lot of
people feel all the time.
Yeah. That's a big deal
for me. The same thing,
just going off a half a burger and,
and was feeling so sick. And then I was
like, man, I used to live like this.
Every meal and my body, you
know, is, is just the, you know,
testament of what your body is capable
to adapt to, you know. But, um,
once you start going the other way
and started really getting healthy,
you really in your body
becomes more sensitive to it
and you really are like, oh,
I prefer not to cheat. You know?
Yeah. You still got to have that.
You've got to have fun.
There's nothing wrong with an ice cream
or something like that every now and
again or some sort of a dessert.
But really it's the,
they just think that your body has to
be accustomed to getting what it needs.
That's what it is. And for too many
people that running on nutrition deficit,
so when your body's just not getting it,
what it needs for long periods of time,
then you develop chronic inflammation
and all sorts of other problems.
And this is what people are really
suffering from. You know, you're, there's,
they're suffering from a
nutritional deficiency that's
probably lasted for years.
They probably never did it. You know,
some people, they just, they go 10,
15, 20 years without even thinking about
their dying. There's eating dog shit.
You just eating stuff that doesn't have
enough nutrients and your body just
starts to get weaker.
There's no way around it.
And if you just just turn
that starting salads,
eating a healthy fish
and, and, and you know,
some healthy meat and just take some
vitamins. It takes a vitamin supplements,
real simple, you know, slot and just
get yourself some multivitamins,
give yourself like a little thing of
athletic Greens or something that get,
get your fucking health online.
And once you do, he'd be like,
Oh,
I've just,
how much better this is all I had
to do and I'm this person now.
Yeah. Mentally. So much better. Much
clearer, much happier. Much happier.
It's so hard though,
cause we love mouth pleasure
like [inaudible] you know,
but to the point where
people were poisoning their
bodies to get mouth pleasure.
Yeah. And it's just, you know,
constantly pushed in your face.
Everybody always knows. We talk about
all the tie in on the cheeseburgers,
50 cents salad, like five, $6. You know,
is you have to make that effort.
You have to be able to want to cook at
home and it's not, it's not made easy.
And that's what I think,
um, we become as a society,
less cool and less appreciative of effort,
you know? Yeah. But there's also,
there's something really annoying about
people that want you to eat healthy.
Yeah.
That to get off your high horse.
Oh Fuck Outta here.
If you're sitting there and you're having
a burger and fries and enjoying the
shit out of it and some asshole next
use got Kale was shaved pecans and
talking shit about your diet while
they're pouring fresh olive oil on top of
their shitty salad. C'Mon
man. Leave me alone.
You know, even a little wine or enjoy
something gross. Yeah. Taste around.
I think as long as the, the majority
of your diet is really healthy,
then you can get in those fuck off days.
It doesn't matter.
Your body will bounce back. Just
don't, don't put it in a deficit.
That's the whole key. And that's
where I'm coming from. And that's,
that's why I had to,
I have to keep reminding myself cause
I get frustrated when I'm at the,
like these parties or whatever and
see, you know, there's food everywhere,
craft everywhere.
And I'm like,
I have to stay on focus on his diet
cause I'm like, I, you know, I'm 36 now
and I want to make sure that I'm at
my healthiest and then I returned as
devastate when I'm 40.
You know,
because when the natural aging process
cakes and I don't want to be like kicking
off still being, you know, two
30 to 200, hundred and 20 pounds,
I want to be like 200 and be able
to coast and be a hot old man.
Hot old man.
Yes.
Because it's also way easier
to maintain is less true. Yeah.
Um,
it's way easier to maintain two than
it is to like if you're in your 50s and
then you start working out then
is hard. It's really hard. Like,
it's hard for me when I get out of shape,
like if I get hurt or something like that
and I take a couple weeks off, that's,
you feel it. Like whoa. It's way
harder to bounce back. Way Hard.
Like twice as hard as it
was when I was younger.
Like you gotta be disciplined it down
the horse. Yeah. Stay on a horse.
That's what I've been trying to
do now is um, I think, you
know, when you're younger,
twenties teens or whatever,
you don't want to listen to anybody
saying those things. And now I'm like, I,
I'm starting to listen when someone I
know in one of my friends are 50 or older
and they're like, hey, you need
to do this now because yeah.
One cheat meal for me
is two weeks of work.
Yeah. Yeah. Um,
do you do anything like
athletic that's fun? Like, uh,
that's one way to get good workouts. And
like if you play a game, you like, tennis.
Tennis is a very fast paced, people
like doing that gives them a good car.
Like Callans and tennis. Boxing
counts in a boxing too. Like anything,
meaning we don't have to box a
person and I don't recommend you do,
but just hitting a bag. It's like,
it's really satisfying too. Yeah.
I've been interested in
getting in the boxing. I um,
I tried some pro wrestling for a little
bit. I went to a pro wrestling school.
Yeah. What about, have you ever
thought about actual grappling,
like taking Jujitsu or get hurt easily?
Well, you could, but you're a smart guy.
I think you'd figure it out
pretty quickly. It's, it's,
it's a very unusual thing
because, um, you think of people,
like if you thought of someone who does,
does Jujitsu, you'd think like, oh,
like a jockish type person.
But the majority of them that
are really good are really nerds.
That's what I've met a couple.
Okay.
People and they all like,
um, they're similar to me.
They're just kind of like the other
side. I mean, we were like, oh,
you like comic books and Video Games too.
You just beat people up.
Well, they don't beat people
up. They tried to strangle
him. But when I say nerd,
I mean, I mean it with all due
respect that there, you know,
cause I'm a nerd and a lot of ways
with some things, but they, they're um,
they're very like Jujitsu geeks.
They're like people that are
obsessed with uh, anything else,
whether it's music or video
games or they become obsessed,
but they're doing it in the physical
way that requires you to have a deep
understanding of all the potential moves.
It's very complicated in terms
of like your ability to when you,
when you're rolling with someone,
say if I roll
with a guy and I know he's like a brown
belt or a black belt or something like
that,
I'm,
we're having an argument or conversation
with techniques and the more of a
vocabulary you have and the stronger your
use of those words are as particularly
the basic words, the better your
chance of winning the argument.
That's what it's like.
Almost like this really complicated debate
with physical leverage and they feel
like that kind of reminds
me of your style. It. Um,
it definitely,
like,
it's like a lot of what I try to
do is like figure things out in a,
in a joke form. Right. I'll try.
Like, what, why is that? What's that?
So like that's what I've been trying
to do over the last few years,
I think.
So in that sense it is kind of similar.
That's cause you're trying
to figure something out. Like
it's, it's like a puzzle.
Like there's, I know there's some
juice in this puzzle, like, how do I,
how do I turn this into a bit? Why
do I think this is funny? Like,
what do I think I can say out of this?
That's funny. And also people go,
Oh yeah, Huh, hmm. You know, and if I
could do that. And so in that sense, yeah,
it's Kinda like, it's, but it's
also, it's very human. It's humbling.
It's very humbling because you
getting strangled and like you just,
you lose in power. He also just know,
you know, like my uh, instructors, uh,
John Jacques Machado, he says very famous
Jujitsu black belt, world champion,
Super Nice Guy,
one of the nicest guys in the planet.
But every time I grapple with
him, it's just like a, uh,
it's a matter of time for,
he catches me with something.
It's just,
it's not whether or not I'm ever going
to catch him. That's not going to happen.
This is just a total different world and
a lot of that is his deep knowledge and
understanding something
and you being a smart guy,
I think you'd get into it especially cause
you love pro wrestling. So I was like,
there's like you have at least you have
a mindset for watching guys do things to
each other and manipulate each other,
which is half of what's exciting
about pro wrestling. Right?
Some guy pulling off some crazy move.
Even if it's orchestrated,
it's still a crazy thing that these guys
are pulling off on each other. I mean I,
I liked Mr Cause then I'm like,
oh they're friends and they
worked this out together.
My problem is I know they're getting
hurt and then not even really fighting.
Right. I mean they're, it's,
they're hitting each other for sure.
They're doing things to each other and
slamming each other. It's all real.
But those guys get banged
up and they do it way more.
So if you're watching the guy
who's fighting in the UFC,
they have practices that they can control.
So if they know that they
have a hurt, uh, you know,
back or a hurt foot, you know, they'll put
shit in ins to have pads on. They won't,
they won't kick.
They'll do things where they work around
whatever injury they have when they're
in the camp. You can't do that when
dudes are throwing you. There's some,
you've got a bad back and some guy's
fucking picking you up and bang. Oh,
they will. You know, they'll look
just swept. They will do. But I,
I do really like your point about, um,
these, they can take some time off,
I'm sure. Yeah. They can definitely
make an agreement with each other. Hey,
don't slam in my back is fucked.
But those guys get beat the fuck up.
Talking to a Dallas page and Jake the
snake to guys that have had on the
podcast, which were, they were
amazing and especially Jake stories.
Fucking crazy man. When he tells
you his story and what a nice guy,
big giant,
nice man,
like just genuinely friendly and happy
that everything's going well for him now.
Crazy. But that's a rough
business is my point. Like I,
I'm way rather like real uh,
grappling.
Like I feel like real grappling for like
if it was going to tell a person like
what would be safer for your body?
I think pro wrestling is harder.
I think it's harder on you. I can see
that they don't, they get saw, wham,
you watch some of that stuff.
No one wants you to know now about brain
damage and knowing what you know now
about that it's not even concussions
necessarily as much as it's sub concussive
trauma that doesn't knock you unconscious,
but just rattles your fucking head.
And the repeated impacts of those. Yeah.
Those guys are getting that all the time.
Yeah. All the time. Yeah. No,
I go back and sometimes that why some
older wrath land and it really makes me
cringe because they got a
lot of guys could take it in.
All these chairs shots straight to
the face. Straight to the face. Yeah.
It's all kinked.
Ken Shamrock,
take this one to the head that
sounded like a gunshot. It was crazy.
Dude. What is it about people
getting smacked in the head? Um,
Thompson girl has been sending me
these Russians slap championships,
his videos. Have you seen
this shit? Oh my God.
These guys stand in front of each
other and smack each other in the face.
Full clip.
But some of them are doing a terrible job.
They're hitting with their finger and
left finger. They're getting fingers.
And then there's other guys
that are basically doing
like a ridge hand strike to
your neck.
They're clipping guys on the chin
like this and they fall through it.
It looks like a slap.
But this is not a slap this,
this is like a karate chop there.
They're like going like that
to the head and then it turns,
I mean it's way harder.
And then some guys are doing like
a boss route and palm strike.
They're hitting like this.
There's the doing like a right
hook to the head like that.
It's brutal guys or get
knocked unconscious.
I like to see it but just
with like older black moms,
they used to be the dumbest thing ever.
It was called like x arm and they would
take these guys arms together and let
them have an MMA fight.
What?
It was an MMA fight slash arm wrestling
competition and they were taped together.
It sounds so stupid. You can't
imagine that not only was it real,
but that the guy who created it was one
of the original creators of the UFC,
like it's such a crazy idea.
They just went for it, man, look,
they taped these people together.
Their arms are taped together.
They can't even move away and then
when they say go, they start fighting
and they get an arm bars. Sky
Floats. This guy's arm up, dude.
He broke his arm on the table 100% if
that guy keeps pulling on that thing,
he gets his arm snapped. Yeah, no,
I don't know if he actually
broke her right there,
but if the way the leverage of that table,
because that guy's getting kicked in
the fucking head while he's tied to that
guy's arm. It's crazy. Pin His arm,
pinned his arm or Kao
him to win. What? What?
What didn't work? I mean it
didn't last. I can see why.
Just sub crazy people can get,
I love it dude. But that's real.
And how this is the other one. Chess.
Boxing. This is a legit one too.
I think they a box first and
then they play chess, right?
I think it goes back and forth.
Oh, they keep going back and forth.
That's a good move.
But seriously,
if you get out of the ring,
what if you get chaos?
Do you win if you win a chat?
Yeah.
Like if you win it chess,
but you get flat lined in 30 seconds.
Whew.
That's also be really fun.
If there is people who are horrible at
fight am but really good at test. Yeah.
And they would just lay down like you win,
you win this part.
I'm just here for the chest.
I know you guys suck at chess.
Why do they have headphones on
focus? You think so? Really?
While they're playing chess.
Oh, like to drown out the crowd.
Oh cause people would
probably say no to route.
It looks like the fight was first.
Yeah, there's sweat. By the way.
Nights we're up to probably
isn't even a real move.
I just said some numbers and some letters.
I don't understand anything when it comes
to playing chess out loud was friends
with this guy that was
in prison in prison.
He learned how to play chess with
his words, you know, with uh,
it was just in his head.
And um,
he was at this place that we used
to play pool at in white plains.
New York is called executive billiards,
a classic old school pool hall.
I think it's done now.
I think they,
they just closed it down
or something like that.
Maybe they're renovating or something.
But um,
this guy was playing with this kid who
was like a world champion chess player
and this kid would come by and play pool.
This really young kid like like 1516
years old and the two of them were sitting
there playing chess with each
other, like just saying, you know,
night to queen to or you know,
whatever the fuck it means.
And the guy would go stand there,
go a rook to six, blah blah blah.
And they would go back and forth
like this. I'd be like, I was like,
what are you imagining
what they're seeing?
Like what are they seeing in their head?
Or they seem like these things
move around in three dimensions.
Are they looking at it as a grid?
How are they keeping track
of where they're fucking
pieces are? It was humbling,
very humbling as it's just
strategic mind that I do not have.
What was interesting to me too,
cause it was a very young man.
I think it was like 23 or 24 I got to
see how fucking smart this guy was.
Yeti still wound up in prison. So
it was like, okay, like all right.
Just because someone's a criminal
doesn't mean they're stupid.
And just because someone smart doesn't
mean they won't go to jail. Absolutely.
Those are two things I saw
talking to that guy and uh, he,
he was in the middle of the game once and
he was gambling with this guy and this
is the guy from prison who was like
Super Smart Guy, very sharp guy. And um,
he was talking to the guy who
was playing. He said, dude,
my wife told me if I don't get home by 10,
she wants a divorce and a 10 o'clock
rolls around and he yells out,
I guess I'm getting a divorce.
It's like two hours later and
he'd just racks the balls.
He was there till like two o'clock in the
morning. But it was hilarious. He just,
he, he said like as they started
playing it, my wife says,
if I don't come home by 10,
those are weird times, man.
Growing up, um, in a like
a, a suburb of Boston,
which was a really nice place.
I grew up in this place called Newton,
like real quiet,
quaint little community to go from that
took the CD pool halls of New York was
really weird for me.
Very, very educational.
I got to see all these
like street hustlers,
I get to hang around with these guys,
be friends with a lot of homeless guys.
Like I had guys that were like a pool
players that wound up staying on my couch.
They had nowhere to go, you
know, a couple of them. And uh,
one of them who became my best friend,
this guy named Johnny,
but it was like we'd be in all these
weird places gambling like he's weird,
strange places with these guys who were
like these semi professional players
playing for hundreds,
thousands of dollars.
And it has to be a big crowd of guys
all gathered around. And B, one,
two in the morning. And I'd be thinking,
these guys, these are older than me. Men,
like they don't have families.
Like what did they do?
Like this is a whole separate culture, you
know? And you were in the underwear. Oh,
it was in a lot of ways, men, a lot
of ways. It was very underworldy.
I was obsessed with it to men.
I just wanted to play pool all the time.
I wasn't very good. Um, but the
guys I was around were very good.
I was around a lot of guys who are very,
very,
very good and you got to see like the
excitement of these. Uh, it was like,
it wasn't just excitement that everybody
was gathered around [inaudible] and
that they were playing this
game for a lot of money.
It was also the excitement
that we were bending the rules.
We're all just a bunch of men hanging
out at this smoky place at one o'clock in
the morning on a Wednesday and,
and everyone is in it together.
We're all just in some way
deranged derelicts, you know,
some Weirdos from society that can
figure their way to be able to be at this
place at one o'clock in the
morning on a Wednesday. Like,
why the fuck are you here man, I don't,
you have responsibilities. And no one,
there hadn't been responsibilities.
Everyone.
There was some sort of
either a professional gambler
or they had like some,
one of the guys was a fireman who would,
they would,
they would put them on these 24 hour
shifts and then we would have a couple of
days off and just come to pool hall
and hang out. Watch guys gamble.
I mean it sounds similar. Didn't stand
up. Oh yeah man, man. The myth fifth.
Well that's one of the reasons
why I fit in there from stand up,
you know like starting doing stand up
from 21 then being around these pool hall
guys when I was like 23 or 24 I was like,
oh you guys are like my fucked up friends.
And I like,
it's like too many people out there think
that there's like only one way to live
your life. Like there's a, there's a
bunch of ways to live life. There's a lot.
Yeah,
it's a whole lot of worlds and everybody
wants you to think that Darryl way of
living life is the way
you should go about it.
It's real tricky because they all want
like the sort of confirmation bias they
want. They want you to confirm they
want to. Well, it's more like a,
a confirmation desire.
They want you to confirm that
they're doing the right thing.
If you listen to them and then you
become happy and uh, you know, they,
they come up to you and they go, hey man,
I'm really, really excited that you, uh,
you told me how to do it this way
because now I'm just living my life much
better. Thank you very much. That
people love to hear that. Like, Hey,
I'm right then I am living my life
the right way. It's not right way.
No. He know how many paths. Yes, be
nice. Be Positive, work hard and do it.
Do what you want, man, that's moving.
I would have never got here if
I listen to people, you know,
it's impossible.
They don't even know what they're saying.
People give you advice when they're
absolutely not true what they're saying.
They just say track. They
practice on you. They get,
sometimes people give
you advice and it's real.
Sometimes people have great advice.
Sometimes people are really mean. Well,
and sometimes people are just practicing.
Yeah. They're like, this is in general.
How can anyone give you advice that does,
doesn't relate to something
that happened to them. You know,
they're only going by their life
experience. So that was one thing. Um,
I learned from the Chris Jericho,
another wrestler where he was just like,
you don't listen to unsuccessful people
because they don't know how to do it.
Why would they tell you?
Of course they're going to tell you you
can't do it because they couldn't do it.
A successful person will tell you,
you can do it. Most people I know,
like if you tell someone that, hey,
I want to go try comedy, you know,
if you've only, if you have the
balls to get up there and do it,
they're going to support you,
you know?
Yeah.
And there's this planning those
people out there on both sides.
There's plenty of people out there that
will give you good advice and really
care and want you to do well in your life.
And there's plenty of people that don't
want to see anybody doing any better
than them and then not doing that well.
There's a lot of that.
There's a lot of that that's a sickness
that we've got to forgive people for.
Cause I had it when I was a young man
for sure and I think many of us struggle
with it.
It's one of the things that made me
realize that I was looking at stand up the
wrong way and turns where
like other people to stand up.
And I was looking at other people stand
up as like a comparison to mine in that
uh, I was judging like who's
the best? Who's doing better?
Who's this? Who's that?
And I realized like that is so
stupid.
Like I should just be a fan
of comedy and do comedy.
And so I shifted the way I thought
about it. So it's instead of like,
when I would see someone
killing, I'd be like, God,
I wish I thought of that bit or a God,
he's doing so good shit.
Now I have to follow them instead.
Somewhere along the line,
I got to a place where you're
like, this is great, this is funny.
Like I love the fact that this guy's fun.
Now I can become a fan of comedy again.
Yeah.
Instead of like being wrapped up in my
own creation of it and producing my own
stuff.
Yeah. Well I always not though
always on a similar journey.
I was very competitive,
not but maybe a year or two ago.
And again,
in the relationship that I'm in now has
been very helpful because she's a big
fan of comedy and she always wants to
watch comedy. And so then I'm always like,
okay, I have to just not be, I just have
to enjoy these people too because yeah,
you're right there. They're great.
And, and, and I had to learn,
like I don't want everybody to be doing
the comedy that I'm doing or I'm not
special. I want to see all these
different types of styles. I think,
I mean the fact that me and you are in
this room together and we both respect
each other's comedy in our comedy
worlds apart in different, you know,
just two completely different styles.
But we both respect each other because
we both know that we are authentic in
what we do. You know, I, if I were to
try to be like you, that would make
no sense. I was trying to be
like, you know, people would go,
what's going on man?
What are you doing up there Joe?
Smoke too much
slow down man.
You want that?
What does that self Kratom
a lot of people on that cradle. No,
I respect the fuck out of you man.
And I respect your process.
You know, you're uh,
like we were talking about it as
a, as an art form, as this um,
structure based, you know,
like you, you structure things,
you know how to set
things up is so important.
Then we don't have anyone
to tell us how to do it.
We have to kind of like learn from each
other and learn from the greats of the
past that we can, you know, we could wash.
But it's in a lot of ways it's sort of
an undocumented art form in terms of the
creation of the art form.
And part of the problem is that
everybody has their own way of doing it.
Like that's why I asked you like, do
you write down, do you, uh, do you type,
do you just have some,
some of the best just to have
ideas and they don't write shit.
And then they go on stage a lot and then
they work those ideas out when they're
on stage and they work those ideas out
in their head and they keep everything in
their head. You know, there's a lot of
guys who are really great who don't,
they don't write,
they just write in the moment.
They're right on stage and they have
ideas and they flesh them out and he
continued to work on them
and they just stay active.
And I never have to actually sit and
write. And there's some of the best.
And then there's guys who write every
day and there's some of the best. And I,
it's like, fuck man, I don't think
there's a right way to do it.
I think is it just us to have,
you just have to care and you have to
be trying to get better? Yes. A hundred,
hundred 70
zero. It's gotta be effort
and not going back in.
Like what I'm trying to do now is as be
a little bit more picky because I go,
I like did my special, and then
I go write a joke and I go, oh,
you're basically doing an extension of
what you've already written and like,
don't, don't do that. Like, let's try
something new. Let's go some more.
If you don't have it this,
just go up there and relax a bit.
Live life a little bit. Yeah. Because
most of my materials personal anyway,
you know, I don't really do a lot of
topical, so for me to generate material,
I usually have to be active in
life and that things happen to me.
Yes, yes. Yeah. I think, um,
I think it's really important to be around
a lot of other people that are doing
it really well too. You know, I'm,
one of the things I really get out of La
was on any given night I can go to the
store and watch someone murder, you know,
quick all the time and were like, no,
I'm one person, like six, seven,
eight people Kaelin in their own way.
And you just around that,
did you just get this like extra juice
out of that place? Man, you know,
you get extra juice out of La, out of
the store a lot of times have the Improv.
It's like there's just,
there's so many of us here.
It's a crazy hive of comedians if you
really stop and think about it. Yeah.
You know,
I mean Jean Diaz and Burger and you know,
a Segura is here, you know, you're here.
Deleah I mean it's just fucking every
week that places mom Marin's here.
It's like Theo Vaughn's here. It's
just, it's chaos. Sebastian's here.
Yeah.
Like Holy Shit.
You might get a drop and from Chappelle
and you all the time. Yeah. All the time.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's one of the weirdest places ever
in terms of like a hive of comedy.
And we're so lucky to be in that hive,
man,
be watching all the shit go down in 2019.
You know,
this is an epic time for standup.
Yeah. That's the thing. It ain't no,
don't like to bring it up all the time.
But like when something like what Brody's
passing happens, I have to go like,
oh yeah,
it's stabbing and so in the rat race and
so competitive all the time and worried
about what you're making and realize that
the true gift is the time that you get
the spin with these truly unique minds.
You know,
the people who don't think like me at all,
people who like you say you,
I see jokes every day where I go,
oh fuck.
Like how like that was in
the air for anyone. Yes. Yes,
yes, yes. That's the weirdest feeling,
right? When you're like, fuck,
how did I miss that?
God dammit.
Tony Hinchcliffe has a joke right now. I
don't want to give it away, but, uh, it's,
it's one of those where he's, he does
it. I go, God, I miss that. So good.
Santana has got this bit about
candles. Then I'm like, ah, you know,
I worked with them all weekend. I was
in Austin with him. He's great. Yeah.
I love him. To George Perez to George
Perez murdered, murdered in Austin.
Oh yeah, it did. Cap City Comedy Club.
I wanted to go do the comedy for a goof.
I need to, uh, do more comedy clubs. Uh,
it's just such a different
thing that you're rich comic,
do the club as a goof.
You make a decision whether you want to
make a lot of money or have a lot of fun.
Yeah, true. Truly. Yeah.
Yeah. And I'm, it's not that,
it's not a lot of money to work in a club.
It's, it's great money. It's not bad,
but it's, um, it's a different
choice. It's like the choice
of a right now for me,
the choices we'll,
how about just trying to make my shit
make more sense and more reps in front of
different people. And, and, and more
feels more different vibe. You know,
every time you go on stage you're in a
different place. Audience is different.
Introduce yourself to new people.
Yeah. Well, I'm trying to do,
I'm getting ready to go out on a tour
and I specifically was asking my Mike,
my people were like, I was like, I
want to go to Huntsville, Alabama.
We want to go to like,
I want to go to these places
that you don't expect to see me.
And I want to see a,
because I think it'd be cool to just
bring in people who were like, hey,
why are you here? And I want to see,
um, that's why I'm going to Australia.
I just want to see, make my comedy
travel. And I will, I'll learn,
I'll learn how to,
I'm sure I'll go in there and I'll say
something as too American and I'll be
like, oh, okay. Right.
And it'll just denote inform my writing
and I would start writing more globally
and, and you know, and those are the
type of things I'm looking for it now.
They're, they're fantastic.
Australia is great.
They're like a alternative Americans.
And I say that a good way, like in,
and they're like a degree
nicer than Canadians.
So I could get Canadians who,
where I say there's 20% less douchebags
in Canada than there is the United
States. You could always
find bad people everywhere.
But then you've got people from Australia,
I think they take that another 10%.
It's like one of the nicest people
ever. They're so nice. Ah, can't wait.
The fucking great man. Their shows or
shows over there. Amazing. You know,
and they're, um, they're, they appreciate
it. They know most of our shit. You know,
they understand most references
and things that we will talk about.
But if you knew a few about
them, it would, it would
probably help them relate to,
but it's, it's a weird culture. It's,
it's a place that I would totally
live if I didn't live here.
If I didn't live in America or it didn't
live in Canada, I want to go anywhere.
I'm not saying I want to leave America,
but I said if I did,
yeah, but you travel and you go that
you, you, you find a place. Okay,
this is fun to visit.
And then you find those places.
I'd like to me like Italy is nice to
visit by. Like, I could never live here,
but then I go to Amsterdam and I'm like,
I live here. This is like Portland,
this is great. But like
Portland. Yeah, Portland sort
of fashion itself. After that,
when it became legal to have
weed there too. Right. Have you,
did a lot of those places were comparing
themselves to Amsterdam way back in the
day. You know, it's funny.
Amsterdam was a place where people
would actually go there to get high.
It's like the, the very first high
destination. Like people try broke,
we're going to go to Amsterdam,
get high.
I like going just for the vibe of like
we were talking about earlier of um,
no stigma and there is no, like someone,
if, you know, I dropped something on the,
wherever the people,
oh,
you stoner. Like there's nothing like that
in Amsterdam. And I love that feeling.
It's a dumb thing here.
That's just a remanent of propaganda.
End Dumps donors that are real people.
You know what I mean?
There's always that time where you're
running to someone who is too high and
you're like, aw man, you're just
fucking up the whole stereotype, man.
You're perpetrating sir.
Oh,
you can smoke a bowl and others not
coming out of your nose like, yeah,
there was certain people
that just get too high.
Yeah,
they just get too high or too weirded out
by life. And you're like, Bro, slow down.
Or right now you're okay. I
know everybody's okay. Yeah,
the end is horrible for everyone and
anyone, but right now you're okay.
So if you can't be happy now when you're
okay and you're worried about the times
when you're not going to be
okay, that is madness. All right?
So you've got a police off out
of madness and be in the moment.
In the moment everything's fine,
but that's a tight wire walk when you're
high as fuck. Right when you're sober
is it is.
So do you see they let that dude off
the empire guys? I let them slide.
I love it. It makes it so
exciting for me. I've been,
I've been, I lived them on class couple
of days, told my girlfriend I go, I go.
The craziest thing would be if they say
he's not guilty because then you have to
go, what happened? What
happened? What happened?
Did he bribe somebody or did some new
evidence come forth that they had a bad
investigation?
Did the two guys that were his witnesses,
did they get caught lying
about something else?
You know the witnesses against him,
they might've caught them lying about
something else and they don't know what to
do and they have to abandon the case.
Cause then they obviously know that he's
a lot, these guys lied about something.
Who the fuck knows man?
I'm understanding I can make a guest
and as they won't be educated but,
and just know in Chicago in general,
I'm in,
my guess is maybe the way they were going
after the investigation wasn't really
above board. And if they,
if they, if he's just like,
I'm not guilty and they have to actually
go in and present this evidence,
they don't have, you know, they don't have
what they really need to have, you know,
like I don't, I don't think anyone's
going around like, okay, yeah,
well then those two Nigerian
Maca guys did attack him.
Mager guys, it's so great. Well
then also they sealed the case.
So fun. Yeah, it's crazy. Yeah. If
you wanted to like a good twist,
you know,
in the movie,
like this is a crazy scene in the movie
were crazy music is playing and you see
Jesse Smollett come out in slow motion
and put his sunglasses on and get into
the limo guilty
and he comes out in slow motion and gets
in the Limo and then dudes are wearing
ski masks and people are
pulling on it. It's like, uh,
like one ongoing story.
And one of those Tarantino movies.
Well you got four stores like
pulp fiction battling it out.
He's one of them where he gets not guilty
and it becomes a big twist cause you
feel like you find out that some behind
the scenes shenanigans and shit that led
to this cause what happens? People are
like, oh, he's never going to work again.
But now not guilty. So does he get
his own show? It's a good question.
What happened?
Well,
the other thing is for live the longest
time Chicago has been thought to be a
place that is like a,
you know,
like things can happen there. You could,
you could make shit happen. Right.
Is that a fair way to say it? I love
Chicago. I don't want to be disparaging,
but there's been some, uh, some
cases of corruption. Oh yeah. No,
I mean that's where I was
raised it very corrupt place.
Most of our mayors and stuff go to jail.
So I don't think I'm being
unfair. Yeah, there's a,
there was a scene in a movie.
What was the scene in the movie where
someone's Chicago is the most corrupt big
city. Illinois. Third, uh,
most corrupt state in the country ties.
Yeah,
that's cray published February 15th.
So this shit, this is recent. Uh,
oh my goodness. Yeah.
Um, I don't know man.
I don't know about Chicago. I'd be
talking out of my ass, you know,
I know him a little bit. Tell me
what it's like. It was very cold.
It was very cool. We're up locked right
then. Sometimes it's very hot. Right?
Is he is either usually too cold and
shooty a very hot and shooty and then the
spring is delightful.
Shooty
that's the best verb ever
shooting to shooting.
This is a little too shooty over.
That's fucking hilarious. Shooty yeah,
it is a it's way, way, way, way,
way too shooty. Right. And um,
do you think that people, I, this is my
opinion, I want to know if you agree.
I think the people in colder
areas like Detroit and Boston,
Chicago,
like there are different kinds of people.
There are hardier people than people
that grow up. Like in San Diego.
No disrespect San Diego. I'm sure a
lot of you are hard, hardest fuck.
But there's like a difference between
people that have to shovel snow and deal
with that fucking winter and be holed
up and really be fucking freezing.
Like when you come in from
outside like fuck, fuck, fuck.
And you appreciate the warmth of a
nice restaurant or something like that.
When you walk in from out of the
cold people shoveling snow is,
it's windy as hell. And then you got like
very aggressive homeless people there.
So you're going to, yeah,
you're going to get tougher.
I had to program that for myself when
I moved from Chicago to Oregon because,
and then taught as a teen.
It was always like even my walking,
my walking was too slow for Oregon because
I would walk and I take a look back
cause that's how my mom taught me to
walk and Chicago's make sure nobody's
sneaking up on you. And in
Oregon they didn't have, they
didn't have that concern.
Yeah.
Fuck,
that's a weird way for a kid to grow up
to men always be worried about danger.
One of the strange things about that is
that it's very hard for people to get
over that hump.
It's a very hard for people to just
calm down after they've been in a bad
environment for a long time.
You get wired a certain way and even
though you're in a new place now and
everything's calm,
you're still looking out.
You're still thinking this
shit could go sideways.
You've seen people go
sideways. Yeah, yeah.
That's why it's hard to be
in a relationship with me.
Something I miss about when it was snowing
and you would go outside and it would
be silent, you and your anything. It
was one of some of my favorite times.
I live in,
in Boston or in Newton where I was.
I lived right across the street from the
Charles River and there was this like
this big grassy area in front of my house
and you just look at, oh, the white,
it would just be Oh, thick white snow
and it muffled everything like it looks,
so it was sound insulation for everything.
You didn't hear shit.
You know that feeling, Jamie,
you grew up in Columbus.
You know when you get a like a
big snowstorm storm it's like,
it's just like sound deadening everywhere.
There's no hard edges anymore.
Everything is covered with snow.
It's just,
it feels good. It would feel good.
It would feel like this is nice.
As long as you have food,
as long as you know it's going to go away.
As long as the plows are still running,
as long as you have either firewood
or backup generator or something.
Sometime that electricity cuts
out and then everyone gets scared.
Noddles up together.
I remember that episode of I love Lucy.
Did you ever have that happen? Yeah,
now did take the fine. I did too.
Everybody does.
If you live in a place where its nose at
some point in time the power goes out.
I remember these guys in Toronto were
telling me their power went out for two
weeks and it was fucking crazy cold like
in the Zeros and below zero and they
were doomed. I mean there's
ice everywhere. I said need
the power lines fall down.
They had a,
you know,
like frozen rain had come and covered
everything when ice and things were
breaking off and power was outed and
like blocks and blocks and blocks and all
these people in fucking the dead of
winter in a city we're endanger day.
Scary, scary shit man. Because
you know me man, you firewood,
you don't have a place to burn it.
You're in a goddamn apartment building.
What are you going to do?
Everybody's fucking freezing.
No one's going to help you.
The phone doesn't work.
It's not fucking power is stuff you
think about a lot though. Right?
Cause you only talk about that like the
so coddled wit you know about the thin
veneer of civilization.
That's what I think about and when I
think about it more than anything is from
natural disasters.
That's what I think about.
I think about the potential for
natural disasters. There's this,
it can happen at any moment and most
people have no preparation for it
whatsoever. They have no idea what they
would do. It just seems that if you,
if you're paying attention to history
at all, you know that this happened.
It happens all the time. It almost just
happened that one that you were, uh,
you pulled up the other day
that happened in December,
some asteroid that blew up
in our atmosphere that had
five times the power of a
Hiroshima.
Okay.
10 Times, 10 times the power of
Hiroshima blows up in our atmosphere,
mother Fucker, man, that hits, that
hits Chicago right in the face.
That can happen. I mean, it's
happened all over the world before.
There's a total possibility that we can
get hit with a chunk of iron the size of
a fucking ocean liner and it just
slammed into a city, a nukes, that city.
That shit happens. I think that, yeah.
Did that bother you or
that it make you more free?
Uh, I would lie to you. It makes
you more for, it makes me more free.
I don't think that's true though.
I think a,
it definitely makes me sound paranoid,
but I've thought about that a lot and
it's just, I'm just being accurate.
But it also, um, uh, pretty, uh,
pretty. You can be boat. Yes.
I tried to be pretty present. Try to be
pretty here. You know as much as I can.
And so if you're here,
like if you present and you
are aware of all these things,
it's just a slippery or grip on present,
but you could still be present and
aware like this ain't going to last.
This whole thing ain't going to last.
So these people are building buildings
right next to the goddamn ocean,
the oceans rising,
you know it's,
there's a real possibility that rocks are
going to slam it in this mother fucker
any day now or a hundred years from now
or five years from now. Nobody knows.
But one day it's going to
happen and it's going to be,
and the fucking earth is going
to ring for a million years.
That's what happens.
Okay,
nice. I mean, I'm okay with that because
it's out of my control in that regard.
It's a good way to look at it,
but it's also
okay.
Seems like Horse Shit because
this world seems very permanent.
This moment seems very permanent.
Life seems very real.
It's been real my whole life every day.
Right?
Life is real. You know, I don't, but
that's it. You know, this too shall pass.
Right. You know, you got it. You
always know it and nothing is, is true.
I think that's one of the biggest
life lessons I had by having a,
I'm not most stable childhood moving
around a lot and bouncing around to
different schools in different
states where I was like,
I learned very quickly that
things aren't permanent.
I learned also that things are very
relative to whatever area you are.
That's what really helped me.
Um,
I think held my voice as a comedian now
is that I've learned very young that
like what's cool is very relative
to wherever you are. You know,
the things that were cool in Chicago,
people weren't on in Oregon and things
that were cool in Oregon or like Greece,
you know, they would get
beat up in Chicago. Yeah.
So I learned very quickly
it'd just be like, Oh man,
just joy what I do and
just like what I'm about,
it's, um, it's really helped my life
be more, more peaceful in that way.
And that's why that,
you know,
36 year old man who owns shit
ton of wrestling action figures.
Yeah,
that's half of the life is trying to
find the balance between being satisfied
and being motivated and being
happy and just being, again,
just being present, you know, just
finding out what you actually enjoy.
Just doing it just to that thing,
you know,
was wrestling action figures and
that's where it's weird. The Path.
Did you think of that
thing would be like comedy,
but then you also learn that you can't,
you can overdose on that
and you can be over. Um,
cause that's the thing I like when I
was started headlining and then I w you
hear these stories and
what w when I was younger,
when like when Greg Geraldo died or
Patrice died and I just get these parts
where I might men that's like [inaudible]
obviously all due respect to them,
not as I said, but I was like,
I don't want to die on a road.
That's not how I wanna live my life.
That I don't want to be found in
some hotel somewhere. I want Mike,
my family around me and
people who care about me. And,
and that really made me be like,
okay,
I have to think about more than
just like each individual set.
I have to start thinking about what
do I want to give back? What do I,
what do I want to do bigger than that?
Like do,
what do I want to do if I just
want to do the road for fun,
if I just want to,
like if I want to move into something
else when my son's 16 he's going to be
going, hopefully he'll be going to
college soon and I want to be like,
I want to be able to spend
more time with him, you know?
Yeah. Your, your life
as a comic, you know,
it oftentimes I find that guys go through
these stages and then the first stage
kind of feel like an imposter. I feel like
a fraud, you know, you feel like, like,
you know, I'm not really that
good at this. And then you,
you get to a stage where you feel like
a professional when you feel you're a
professional and then you start to take,
put more responsibility on you,
on your work. You know, for me,
I think that's right around
when it happened with me,
somewhere around 10 years
in, I decided like, Hey,
I gotta I gotta treat this like I'm an
actual professional and stop fucking off.
I was,
I fucked off a lot.
I went through periods of years where
I didn't write anything or just,
it was really lazy and I had the same sex.
I was doing TV show shit,
like a sitcom stuff and I just wasn't,
wasn't working on the act at all.
But, um, it's just such a more, um,
energized time right now in comedy.
You know, guys like Santina,
like when we're talking about all these
guys that are coming up all, every,
having all this good comedy
around you, it's almost like, um,
like it raises everybody's vibration.
Like the whole,
the whole community like is the better
everybody gets instead of how everybody
used to approach it where everybody
was competing against each other.
And then you kinda like have weird
feelings when you're running each other.
Now everything's like a
different kind of odd,
yeah, it's a, um, it's
a healthy competition.
And one thing I'm really liking is
a change of the presentation of um,
people being more cognizant of like I
want to present like just dressing up
more,
you know,
looking nice or not necessarily
trying to like suit up or anything.
But I see more and more posters are more
and more things where the people are
clearly putting work into their graphic
design and their heart are even.
Um, and I don't want to speak for,
for, for female comedians at all,
but like I'm just noticing a trend more
where women are being not cause it used
to be either like I am the hot
girl or like I'm just a dude.
Like you don't, don't
worry. I might be high,
but you wouldn't know because
I'm wearing a Hoodie, you know?
And now there's just more of these
women being like, I'm just me and it's,
I'm might be hot, but that's not
a part of this. And, you know,
and I see that a lot now,
but they'll still go out there and know,
put other their posters where they're
like in a bikini or whatever. You know,
cause it's like, why
wouldn't you? Right. Like,
just like when I go and I wear a suit,
you know?
But I love seeing people
take charge of that,
of what they're presenting
and not just because,
I mean that's how I use
the dress all the time,
which is where a big purple Hoodie or
whatever, you know. But now I'm more like,
I want to look more like a,
I guess I'm like a star.
Well there's definitely something to I,
you know,
I remember the Martin Lawrence days when
he was on top and me wear those crazy
outfits on stage or Eddie Murphy in Ra,
we wear this crazy leather jumpsuit.
You know,
like he put a lot of effort into what
he was going to wear. It delirious.
That was another one.
Like Eddie Murphy had these crazy costumes
that you could only wear if you were
doing standup. And a lot of ways. I mean
it was the ultimate Eddie Murphy costume.
You know what I'm saying?
Like if you really think about like
him shirtless in a red jacket. Yeah.
Like with Kennison,
what do you picture?
You picture the Baret you
pictured the overcoat,
the picture of the white sneakers.
Like it was his crazy outfit.
He had like kind of a like you would
kind of expected that look from him.
But with Eddie Murphy's, Eddie
Murphy was like, you know,
leather like colored leather and you know,
it was very powerful.
It was very bold, which was
like his comedy, you know,
it was like letting you know this
is a special night is the night.
He doesn't dress like this
every day. Yeah. This is, yeah,
he's on stage doing a show like that.
Yeah. Yeah. Like you and just people who
think about the, the full presentation.
I mean even doing that, like the playlists
that the club plays before my show,
like I've been setting that up now.
Right.
Cause I want a vibe of mostly fish.
I got to
Piss so bad. So I want to keep going
though. I don't want to stop. So, uh,
I was just did two podcasts in a row
and I drank too much coffee. So, Jamie,
why don't you guys talk about something
you have in common. All right. Okay.
You guys have in common, I smoke
smart pot. Yeah. Oh, for sure bro.
Have a freshie thank you. Have an
extra one for the road too, sir.
You're welcome. I'll be right back.
Talk amongst yourselves. Okay, nice.
Welcome Taylor. Ron Funches
the experience, right? You
have your own podcast too,
right? I do. It's called
getting better. Uh,
what Ron Funches when we just kind of,
I talked to people who I admire are
people who I want to learn from,
people who have accomplished things I
want to accomplish or have gotten better
in some form in their life. And I, uh,
ask him about it and about setting
goals and stuff. Do you ever have,
do you just set it up that way?
Like I was a conversation?
Or did you put more thought into like,
I want to ask them these
kinds of questions and get
these kinds of things? Um,
I mean there's just, there's some set
questions I usually just ask people about,
about their goals and I asked
them about some advice to give me.
But other than that, it's usually just
some type of free form conversation.
It's just, you know,
it's funny sometimes, uh,
but for the most part it's just like,
um,
the reason why I wanted to do it is
because I was a big fan of like Patton
Oswalt's website, the spew and
stuff like that. When he had that,
and I noticed like when it was on Twitter,
there had been a shift
from people who are like,
used to be very supportive of me,
especially when it was fatter and stuff.
And then it came this thing of like,
anytime I would try to post
something positive, he will be like,
why the fuck do you fuck?
Who Cares?
You have money and you and you just, you
know, and I just want to be like, no,
I'm not on a different side of the
fence because I did these things. I,
I'm like over here being like, anybody
can fucking do it if my dumb ass dead. It,
you know, so it just became more
about like, to me like talent and,
um,
success is more like this ocean that we
can all drink from. And it's about like,
how did this person get to that ocean?
I don't think there's people who are
talented untalented finding out their past
sort of to where you are now and what
keeps them motivated now. You know,
like once you, people have some success
with what, why, what keeps you going?
You know, it was a question I would
like to know from Joe, you know?
Well he just walked back in
so maybe we can find out.
Hit me with a question. What keeps you
motivated? But you're so successful,
you got a lot of money.
You're doing okay.
Everything Ufc you like accomplish
so many things. So what,
what makes you go to the store on a,
on a Tuesday night,
uh, to work on, stand up? Um,
I don't look when you, uh, when
you get successful at something,
the best thing that it
does alleviate stress,
but it doesn't change the motivation.
The motivation is always
to create something that I
like, that I can be proud of,
that the people enjoy.
Most importantly,
there's a bunch of people that watch
my standup. I gotta I gotta work at it.
I don't want to be an asshole.
I don't want to be that guy that you
come to see my show and you'd go prepare.
He didn't care. He didn't
try, you know. Thank you.
I'm not going to be that. So I look, we
all have that sets. I'll have bad sets.
I'll try.
I'll try my best though.
I fucking try my best and I'm
going to keep trying my best.
Cause I think if I don't,
I leave.
I leave a doubt in my own
head that shouldn't be there.
If I do my best and it just doesn't work,
I have to figure out what was wrong.
But if I don't do my best and it doesn't
work, you feel like shit. Yeah. Okay.
That's true. But I think that,
um, I still feel like shit,
even if it doesn't work and I did my best,
I feel like a failure rather
than a loser. Yeah. But, um,
I think when I was younger going to
doing comedy my twenties and it may,
it might have just had
been a Portland thing.
There was always kind of this vibe
of like, I didn't try my best.
If I tried my best, I would have
crushed it, but I didn't try my best,
so I didn't really fail.
Yeah.
That's a trap that a lot of comics get
into when they are in front of a small
crowd. No more that. Yeah. Take a
little more. Damn. Ron goes deep. Um,
and um, one of the, you know,
those moments when you're a young comic
where someone says something to you and
it really gives you a nice boost. So
like you feel great about it. And uh,
one time,
uh,
I was at the store and there was maybe
like 12 or 13 people in the audience.
The most was like, no, I'll
keep going. It was, um,
and Paul Mooney was in
the back of the room
and, uh, he's 12 or 13 people.
I'm just doing my act and
Mooney starts laughing hard,
like a supportive laugh,
like he's with
you. Ha Ha. Ah, he's Clap Ben
and the knee came up to me after the
show and it goes something to the,
something to extent of your real comic.
Like that's what makes you real comic.
You do those real shows in front
of all those people. You know,
you do a real show. Yeah. You
don't, you don't like say, oh,
there's only 10 people or 15 feet.
You don't have asset.
You go out there and do your best.
Okay.
Yeah, that's a man is always
just so much to learn.
That's what I've been learning to.
Um,
get out of like every
set is the same and like,
this is my material and I've
been at it for a little bit.
But knowing how to shift
my energy for like that,
like you do want to be professional
for that, those 10 people,
but you're not going to do the same
like yelling energy as if they were a
hundred people. You're going to be
a little more intimate. You know,
you gotta make it more of a conversation
and that's what I'm really learning to
do now. Watching, um, I think
for a lot of Comedians, but, um,
that Garry Shandling documentary that
still haven't seen yet seen it. Oh Man.
I love sweater.
He really helped me.
What I'm about me and mindful
about being in the moment.
So I've been really,
like whenever I write a set list now,
cause I usually number it and it has like
a couple of words, um, the first alley,
right? Number one bullshit for as
long as possible because I don't like,
I don't want to just get into
it. I want to, uh, you know,
unless it's like I got 10 minutes
and I have things I want to do,
but for the most part I'm like,
let me get in a moment.
Let me look people in the eyes and see
if I see something not necessarily going
in and just Crowdwork and rip
on people. But let me, um,
let
me just go in and talk about my day for
a second and then maybe that will segway
into my set. And so it teaches me
a new way to get into things. Uh,
more conversational. Yeah.
Again, you're very jazz.
You got a lot of jazz and you Ron.
That's cool. That's a good way to do it.
Cause it always does feel abrupt
when someone begins with a joke.
Sometimes it works though.
Like some people can do it,
they would go on stage and they just
hammer with a first joke and from there
it's off to the races. Like the open up
with a non sequitur like out of nowhere.
I'm bang.
Yeah.
Jeff Ross is really good at like just
changing the tempo in a room. Yes,
yes, yes. He's great at it.
On the off the cuff, you know,
in the spur of the moment type shit.
Cause all those years of roasting and
all those years of fucking with the crowd
like and,
and that show they're doing him in a
towel or traveling and doing that bumping
Mike show where they just, they just
fuck around man. I mean it's crazy.
They just get in front of those people
that walk around all crazy about what
really opens your mind about gain with
this job can be where you could literally
just travel what your friend
and fuck around and sell out.
Yeah. It's amazing. It's
amazing. It's a crazy Gig, man.
It's crazy gig. When you started out
in Chicago, What Club were you at?
Um, I didn't start in Chicago.
I was a ta. I was the,
a young man I left when I was 13
cousins. Um, my mom was in like,
she's in a little negative relationship,
so I went to go live with
my dad in Oregon, um,
and he was also a negative
thing. So, and then, um,
I started comedy in Portland,
Oregon when I was 23, uh, um,
Harvey's comedy club there. Ah, and
um, and then doing some shows in Salem,
eh, there's Chinese food restaurant
called lucky fortune. And then,
then I just started some
shows there and you know,
struggle for Oh, a long
time. And then, um,
think about five,
five year,
then I got asked to do Kona in and then
was new phase and then got divorced and
then it was like, all right, I'm moved,
uh, moved to Los Angeles. And, um,
no,
just I have my son here and she has been
me and him and now my girlfriend and my
mom now lives with me in the last year.
But um,
yeah,
that's pretty much it.
That sounds cool. Is there a scene in
Portland? We started when I started it.
It was pretty much like there, there
had been, um, Seattle has a scene. Yeah.
There been a bit of a,
um,
like an LG scene of like an enough
familiar with like Dwight Slade and shows
rice. Um, and then not really much.
There's just a lot based off of road
gigs tripling. Ryan's going to Idaho.
That's right. Everybody was
talking about those trivial runs.
We had something similar,
which is not as exciting because you
guys were going through the wild west.
I mean, you're going to Montana and
Idaho. Oh, not me, not me. But the people
that did it, the people who did it. Yeah.
I was, um, didn't seem lucky at the time,
but it turned out in hindsight to be
very lucky that the one time that that
booker saw me,
I just a share hardcore.
And so nothing to do with me.
And it turned out to be the best thing
because then I was in this position where
I was like, oh, okay,
well I'm not gonna get Idaho's shows so
I don't have to pander to that type of
audience and I'm just going to be here.
And so I can right now is really just
like, oh, just write what you like.
And that turned out to be the,
um, the best thing for me.
Dude. You could perform in Boise. They
would love you. Oh, I, I've ended up,
I've had no,
I love Boise is like Portland
and it's a very unusual place.
Almost like, I hate talking about it. I
don't want to give out their spot now.
They got good little comedy. Same
building over there. Yeah, there's,
well I think because of the Internet,
there's a comedy scene almost any and
every city people will find a way to get
together and do something.
It's just,
it seems like too much of an exciting
option for people who are fuck ups and
there are so many of us,
there's so many of us, you know,
in one way or another, there's
so many, you know, one,
one form of fuck up or another.
There's so many of us.
Yeah, that's true. I mean,
I don't know if that's necessarily the
true for the way that is set up for us to
go. Um, the structure that is now
just doesn't work as much anymore.
It made more sense in
the past, you know? Um,
and also it is and shown and not be sound
because that's the thing that trips me
out now.
It's like when I was a kid that was
drilled in my head from my mom was good,
a good government job,
get a good government job,
and now that seems like the most
unsteady job you could have,
you know, that just cut your
department. Yeah. You never know. Yeah.
And so one thing I learned,
um,
the standup taught me quickly was
that it's the same stress, you know,
but now I'm in charge.
That stress of paying my bills.
The stress of taking care of my son is
the same whether I'm working for somebody
else or I'm working for myself,
but at least when I'm working for myself,
I'm in charge. Right. You know,
and as long as I have a product
that I can pull it out. If I'm,
if I don't have anything, then I
guess I got to go work for somebody.
But if I had something,
I'd rather have that stress be put on
me then have someone to show up one day
and be like, we're out of business.
Fine. Find someplace else to work.
Yeah. And you're 60 yeah. Yeah. And
they just cut your whole department.
Well didn't,
I mean every fucking single
politician gets in the office,
they want to cut certain departments.
Right.
There's always someone that thinks
something's being overfunded and yeah.
That they're just talking about cutting
social security and food stamps.
And I was like, that seems like the
last thing we need right now. Yeah.
If you can make things,
it seems like if you could make things,
this is like one of the a good time to
be on your own because you could sell
things on the Internet.
You could sell things in a way
that no one could ever sell before.
Like you could set up an online store,
you don't have to have a physical
location and you could just, you know,
if you make something, if
you're an artist, if you're a,
you make pottery or some shit, you could
sell things that you create online.
Like it's pretty easy to do now.
Like this is a place where people can
actually like, oh well if I just did this,
if I figured out a way to do that,
I'm working for myself.
Or You just do it whenever I want
to sell things. People like it,
they put it in their house and then a
lot of people can go in that direction.
It's not.
I mean,
there's people that just aren't creative
and they're not interested in it,
but there's a lot of people are,
and for those people who are just have
a little bit of creativity that they
maybe never really nurtured because
he will work too much. Find a way,
find a way, find a way to get
through with that main plus.
You know who you are because you,
if you,
if your content and how your job
has gone anyway, you're fine.
You know you're not even
thinking about that,
but if you're upset and you're
like, oh, I hate this job.
I hate what's going on my life,
you know that that usually
that might be the case and people love
to say that's easy for you to say.
It's easy. It's easy for you to say
you guys are both already successful.
It's very hard to get started.
I get it. I get it. It is hard.
It is 100% I get it,
but don't think like that.
Just try to find a way through.
The more time you spend thinking on it,
that's easy for you. I know. It's hard
for me. The more time you do that,
the less time you're thinking
of an actual solution. Yeah.
You see the,
I see that all the time.
Especially even like with my weight loss
and stuff, people um, there are like,
oh you could say that you got,
you got to train her.
And it's just like I still had, I still
had the be the guy that vomited. True.
You know,
I still had to be the guy that worked
myself so hard that I threw up and still
win
back. You know, it's like on the ground
or did you make it to a trash can?
The trash can. Not at wrestling. At
wrestling. I as an on the ground. Oh No.
Yeah, cause then they made me clean it up
and I'm like, it's part of the Gig. Yeah,
it really was.
He can't be puking.
[inaudible] yeah man.
If you're working out to the
point of puking, that's intense.
Well, you know, when my body was
coming from places such an activity.
Yeah. How long do you think it took you
for you to adjust to a constant state of
activity? Probably like six months.
That's a great thing though,
that you had the discipline to do that.
That's a great thing. It really is. It's,
um,
it's an underappreciated thing cause it's,
I think it's easy for me to keep
doing what I'm doing. I always do it.
It's part of my natural way of doing it,
but to not exercise and then decide
you're going to clean your diet up and
you're going to start exercising and
you're going to continually do it even
though you're exhausted because your
body's not really prepared for this.
So you must have had a long period of
like, uh, for a couple of weeks at least,
what you're like having your
body try to respond to this,
where it didn't have to do this before
and now you're making it stress out all
the time and it's got to recover and
then you stress it out and it's kind of
recover.
And then
he bought, he's like, what the
fuck dude? What is happening here?
Is this our new life? Yeah. Yeah. No,
that was pretty much that. You can you,
and you nailed it. How long did it take,
um, to lose, to get to where I am now?
The to where you started feeling
comfortable with like normal exercise on a
regular basis or extreme strenuous
exercise, strenuous exercising again,
I think it'd be about, about,
about six months of where I um,
and then also just their weight goals.
You know,
I was about three 60 when
we started it. And then, um,
get an under three 50 was
just like a real difference.
And then when I got into 300,
that was a big deal.
And then when I got under two 50,
um,
and then now like now I'm about
to 20 and anytime I go over to 25,
I can feel it in my knees again.
And um,
cause I had to take a little
break for a few weeks and um,
but now and that was really big
on my mind because I was like, oh,
I have to take a break for three weeks.
Am I going to just blow up again?
You know,
and going through that and seeing that
I can keep my diet and keep my nutrition
and that I got a little
less defined but I wasn't,
I didn't blow up and I was like,
okay that made me relax a little bit more
and it's helped me as far as my comedy
or dealing with
executives and stuff or I am
very much like, oh I needed that.
Like I can, I can figure things out,
I can do it. I have the discipline.
If I really set my mind to something
I can usually do it. Yeah, that's a,
it's a giant accomplishment and
people undermine it because um,
they feel like it doesn't mean as much
because you let yourself get to that
weight. And I think it's a silly
way of looking at it because
I am a firm believer that many of us who
are feeling really good about life and
having a great time here are v very,
very lucky in their
circumstance. Very lucky in, in,
in the people you're around,
the positive influences in your life,
the good things, very lucky cause
shit can be really not good.
And when things are really not
good and people go down the spiral,
whether it's with booze and cigarettes
and heroin or whether it's with food or
whether it's with alcohol or
whether it's whatever, the pills,
if you can go down a spiral,
it's who out of the person that is in
the bottom of the spiral who can pull
themselves out.
Could you,
if you had to start from there instead
of starting from a place of success,
and this is why I think people get cocky.
You wake up every morning like, oh,
I guess everything's okay. You
know, my life's not in the shitter.
Instead think of what it would be like
if you woke up and you were 380 pounds
and this is your new life.
Your new life is you got to get down
from 380 pounds to about 220 pounds.
You got to figure out how to do and
you've got to figure out how to not lapse.
When you're aching with hunger, you've
got to figure out how how your your,
your body has no fucking energy.
It doesn't know how to recover.
It never gets pushed and you have to
push it through that and you have to do
that to the tune of 160 pounds.
A lot of fucking weight, man,
that's a lot of fucking weight.
Most people are not going to be able to
do that. It's a lot of weight to lose.
How long did that take you?
Um,
about two and a half years.
That's a, no matter what, that's
an accomplishment, man. You know?
And it's something that I think that
when people hear that, that you did,
that people realize like, I
can do that too. I can do that.
That can be done. Yeah. That's been
one of the best things about it.
And what it actually keeps me on it is
when I get people reaching out to me.
Like when I post pictures from the past
or, and now and they're like, man, like,
you know, in some ways the use of piss
me out because if people are being like,
Oh, if you can do it then I can
definitely do it. But now it's like,
it's very motivating.
Yeah. It's, you're setting an
example, you know, you, um, you,
you do something and then people,
because you're in the public
eye and he'd do this thing.
They see you do it there, watch
it happen. You know? I mean,
it's one of the cooler things about it.
Like you go in real time,
he could see you two years ago. You could
see you now. I mean, it's crazy. You want,
you really did it, you know? And
when people see that they, and the,
it's not like if you heard that a guy
lost 400 pounds who are like, wow,
that's amazing.
But if you see a guy and you watch them
on a regular basis and he's 400 pounds
and then all of a sudden he loses all
that way. You like what? Look at him.
Watch him do it. You see
him do it. Something about
people needing to see shit.
Like we need to see someone else do
it. And then we can go, I can do that.
You know?
Yeah.
Would you ever even imagine if you
didn't know the people ran marathons,
ultra marathons,
would you ever even imagine that you
would want to just run a hundred miles?
No. You'd be like, what the fuck are
you talking about? No one's doing that.
But then you hear about it and
you see it and he'd go, oh,
I still don't want to do.
He still don't want to do it.
But it changes your idea
of what people do. Yeah.
Oh yeah. Oh, what's capable? Right. So
when a guy like you lose all that way,
it changes people's idea of what if they
may be identify with you a change of
their idea about what they're capable of.
They changed their,
their opinion of those themselves based
on you pulling your life together in an
awesome way publicly.
Nice. Thank you dude.
That's dope. That's, that has
a powerful impact on people.
You know,
this academy,
a lot of dudes out there and gals that
are trying to figure the fuck out of the
hole. They themselves in,
you know, they're like, how
did I get out of this? Like,
how do I, Jesus Christ. I
hate being tired all the time.
No, that's why my, um, that's
one of the things I love my top,
I'll allow my park has, is, and I
try it cause people don't know me,
you know,
and that time on Twitter,
if I'm like if I try to give a visor
things or I'm not even really advised,
just try and be positive.
People go thank you.
Talking about like what do you know,
what do you care?
You run on a TV show and I have to
go like you don't know my history.
You don't know where I came from.
You don't know that I'm like I'm a
single dad of this kid with a disability.
I take care of them myself.
I was boring as crap.
I had had three weeks of a
college community college
education and I had once I
like, it was like, oh,
I got to pull my life together for this
son who is different from other people
and I don't know if he's ever going to
be able to live on his own or are have
his own job or I have to prepare for not,
I had to prepare that if he does,
if he needs help.
I had a pair of payer for all of these
things and it really motivated me and it
pushed me forward. And I like
to, um, now for some reason I,
I dunno if it's like survivor's remorse
or whatever, I'm always like, man,
I feel like so many people can do that,
you know,
not necessarily comedy or whatever,
but I always feel like
people have their own gifts,
they have their own talents and sometimes
we're not told that we're not pushed
in.
Those directions are sometimes where we,
we go through traumas or things in our
lives that damn our light, you know,
and I like to be like,
you.
Anybody can do it because I'm a testament
to that because I should not be here.
Well you, you should because
you chose the right path.
This is what's really critical about
this kind of what, when we, you know,
we talk about people's future
or what they can and can't do.
One of the beautiful things about
standup is that it's a meritocracy.
You're really funny. People love
you. You're not like, that's,
we just want to know you funny. Hey, is
that guy funny? He's funny. Come on in.
Is she funny? She's funny. Okay,
come on in. We'll just, that's it.
And I don't know of that many
other jobs where it's that clear.
There's a lot of jobs we got to do.
All I ask is that you got
to suck that corporate dick.
You got to be in the
office with Satan going,
what the fuck am I doing with my life?
I don't want to be here. You know,
I'm writing down goals. I just want
to do coke. I want to get a Ferrari.
Fuck this job. You know? That's
what a lot of it is, man.
There's a lot of like weird adjuncts,
you know,
and then you get stuck in this fucking
corporate ladder. You get muted,
you get toned down.
There's no,
there's no deviation from the
standard office worker path. You know,
you're in this weird groove,
whereas it is the stand up.
All you gotta do is make the people laugh.
All you gotta do is find this shit.
It's funny. Work on it makes people laugh.
Get out there, get out there, boom, boom,
boom. Oh Shit. You got to go see Ron
Funches. Oh Shit. People start talking.
People start telling other friends.
The next thing you go,
there's agents, there's
managers. You keep going,
you keep going and keep getting better.
Oh my God, you're on TV. Look at you.
Keep going, keep going, keep going.
If you just keep going and working at
it like nobody tells us what to do,
it's fucking beautiful,
but not everybody can get that Gig.
So then there's other gigs
like what Gig do you take?
It seems like you should take the
gig where you make a lot of money,
but that's not the move.
It's not the move and less you can,
your can be sure that you can quit that
Gig in a short period of time because
nobody ever does.
Yeah. Right. Trap jobs allow is, we'll put
them and they had a lot of them were at,
where I grew up with is, is this bank
call center where I was working, um,
because it was the only place, this tiny
town, not many jobs like unless you were,
if you didn't have a college education
you were working at, at subway,
you work in a Sam goody are,
are you a working at this bank and
you were making like 20 bucks an hour.
You're making like double what
you're making at the subway. But
dude
skills that transfer.
So if you want to leave this job,
you got you going back to
the subway and you know,
so there's a lot of people
end up trapped there.
And I knew right away I was like, I
gotta get out. I can't, I mean, Hey,
I'm not a bank die. Uh,
so you know, that's a trap
trap man.
I remember when I was a kid,
I was working at this place called Newport
creamery. It was an ice cream store.
Like w they sold ice cream and hamburgers
and shit like that and there was a
bank that was like right next door.
I would always go in the bank with my
Newport creamery check and I deposit it
and I'd say, hi, this lady.
And then one day I heard, uh,
she had the baby in the toilet and then
left it in a garbage bin and no one even
knew she was pregnant.
And it was one of those like what?
Like we had just a window into madness
like right next door to where we were
working. We were like, what?
That lady that we always said
hi to and the lady got pregnant,
didn't tell anybody and gave birth in the
bathroom at work and put the baby in a
dumpster.
Dude,
I wish you hadn't led with this with a
bank story was a bank story and it was
just a person person working. She could,
if she could have been at a cupcake shop,
it was just, this was a person,
this is a person who was mad.
There were crazy person.
Right. You have to be,
you'd would have to be a crazy version
where no one knows you're pregnant and
then you give birth in a bathroom and the
baby winds up in a dumpster. It's like,
that is, that's the most insane shit
I've ever heard in my life. Yeah.
And that was like right next door to the
ice cream place. And we were all like,
whoa. It's like the fabric, the
fabric of reality had rippled.
We realize like someone can
be that crazy in your town,
in your fucking town right there.
Hi De your town. Oh Man. You
sound like a nice town. No,
it was a nice towel. It what
I mean, it was a very idealic
pretty sheltered up until
people put in babies and things.
Well, just, it was a, it wasn't
a big place, you know. And, um,
when something would go wrong,
it would be odd. You know, like,
you knew the person
I know it's shelter is because you
were worked at a place called creamery
Newport creamery
ice cream for shelter.
Yeah.
That was a sheltered ASP.
Beautiful. I want him to do that.
I want to make that a reality from my,
no, it was a nice place to grow up. Um,
and I had lived in Jamaica plain
before that, which was much, uh,
much worse neighborhood.
It was sketchy.
We lived there for about a year
and then my parents were like,
we gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
Like people breaking into cars and while
you're sleeping and how home break ins.
And it was just a lot of crime,
especially in like 1978 or
whatever the fuck it was.
I guess it was like Haiti. Yeah. So
then we moved to Newton, which is nice.
Are Your parents still around? Yeah.
Yeah. They're still together. My step,
my stepdad and my mom are still together.
They've been together since I was a
little kid. They're a nice couple. Okay.
Have a good time together.
Yeah, I uh, you know,
do you ever wonder what you're going to
be like when you like 75 year old man?
Yeah.
What do you think that'd be cool as fuck.
Cause I mean I don't,
I don't give a fuck mostly
now and imagine later. Right.
Even less just saying all types of
stuff. I see it in my mom, you know,
my mom especially is fine because I can
take her to like random events that I go
to and she just, I try
to be cool, you know,
cause I'm working and she has none
of that cause she doesn't care.
Like my mom's sexually harass
Justin Timberlake. It was great.
It was,
security was about to take her out.
She just doesn't care. Have you ever had
our guests on your podcast? Yeah. Yeah.
She was the second guess or the first or
second episode? Yeah. It's always, yeah.
My Mom's, yeah. I learn a lot from my mom
and she's super dope. And now she's um,
smoking a lot of pot and just, she lived
down. Oh, she lives with you now? Yeah.
She lives in the Pool House and hangs out.
Did you get depressed and in Portland
with the weather did freak out.
Yeah. You did seasonal depression there.
Yeah. Easily. Yeah. People say it's real.
They say even if you take vitamin
D and sit in a tanning bed, yeah.
I mean they'll show you those
lights and all those things,
but she doesn't do it though, does it? No,
not when you're dealing with
three months of straight gray.
It's the rain, not just gray. Oh,
because there's this lack of
color palette in your life. Yes.
You don't get the vibrance. Yeah. Yeah.
When the ocean looks like a d a dull gray.
Yeah.
Even the ocean looks tired like oh right.
As opposed to like if you go to
Mexico, like, uh,
I went to Cancun way back in the day and
the first thing I noticed like how the
fuck is the ocean? That color?
Like, look how pretty it is. Yeah.
It's like all bluish green.
That's gorgeous. Yeah.
If you ever been to the
French Riviera, no. Oh my God.
You want a time when and yeah, same
thing. They have a pebble beaches,
the sand, which is a horrible, but,
but the water is so
beautiful. It's crazy. Yeah.
I grew up, um, in that town,
which was next to the Charles River
and the Charles River went all the way
through Boston. And the Charles River
was like disgusting man. Like you'd,
you see condoms floating in it and you'd
see I saw one pipe and this bubbles
were coming up to the surface. I
was like, what the fuck is that?
And then I saw a condom bubble up and
I went, oh my God, it's a sewer pipe.
And I realized someone was just flushing
their shit and piss right into the
Goddamn river. Oh, like how did
this happen? And I was, you know,
14 and I'm like, what the fuck is this?
Like how the, how am I finding this?
Like you don't have anybody likes checking
to see if the shit pipe is right into
the Goddamn river. Like,
oh my God, it was crazy.
So it wasn't clean by any
stretch of the imagination.
So to see that kind of a clean,
pure like ocean water where like
you were a heard a bone fishing.
Do you know what that is? It's a
type of fishing that people do. It's,
I think they mostly just
catch and release them.
I don't think they even keep most of them,
but they go to Florida and I the,
I think The Bahamas wants to The Bahamas
and they are on these like special
boats that are like, uh, these uh,
boats you can stand on and their fly
fishing for this fish that looks like it
belongs in the stone age.
It's weird,
cool looking fish called the bonefish.
See if he could pull up a picture of it.
I don't know why we're talking about this.
That's how high am,
that's what the law,
that's cool.
Is that a bonefish smoke
small like a Barracuda?
That's a bonefish. See that's a bone
first. That other one was a barracuda.
I think they just had a bad photo.
You see the difference? Like it's,
it's a crazy look in Fishman
and see that water behind them.
It's hard to tell from this image,
but what we're looking as really shallow
water like at the most it's like three
feet deep,
right?
And they're just casting out and they
see these fish coming towards them and
they catch it. It's supposed
to be like super, super
exciting. You do love fishing.
I don't do a lot of fishing but I love
fishing. It's fun. But this is fun.
Like I would assume, I've haven't done
this kind of fishing bone fishing,
but that's what people,
people love.
Like seeing a fish coming and going and
biting your lore like it's very exciting.
Yeah. It's sad to say, but look how clear
that goddamn water is. It was no clue.
There's no condoms.
She says bonefish.
I was watching a video today of a guy
jumping with scuba gear on into the
garbage patch. It's the middle of the
Pacific Ocean. You know? I had knew,
I knew that it is supposed to
be like horrific, but once you,
when you see it in a video,
you're watching just go,
what the fuck is this?
This guy put scuba gear on and jumped
into this. I mean is it was plastic,
you couldn't see anything but plastic
everywhere you look to the left and the
right, it was all plastic.
Like this is huge.
Like several states, large. Yeah.
This shit, this is what
humans are doing to the ocean.
This is, this is a, would you
see them jump in and it's almost,
did they show him jump in or is
this a different video is different.
There's a different video
cause the other one,
the guy starts out on the boat and,
and dives in and what he dives
into is just like plastic soup.
It's fucking disgusting man.
It's crazy. Yeah. Like this.
Um,
so there's this guy that we had on
the podcast name is boy on slot and he
created a device that he's using to try
to pull the plastic out of the ocean and
they'll maybe convert that plastic
and to know things that we can use.
And um, there, I don't think it worked
on the first attempt, but they're,
they're relaunching it, right? Didn't he?
They had to do something to
fix things there. You know,
it's still in like sort
of the prototype stage.
But he's going to have these machines.
There's giant net move around through the
ocean and catch all these plastic yeah.
Bay from getting fish.
That's a very good question.
I don't think there's any
fish living in there. Um,
I bet a lot of fish have eaten
that stuff though. Guaranteed.
This is probably a lot of fish
with plastic in their stomachs. Oh,
a hundred percent. Yeah man,
that's gross. I mean what,
what kind of shit gets in their system
and then when you eat that fish,
what kind of shit are you
getting in your system?
How many people were testing their fish?
You know, I mean how many people are, uh,
before they eat a Sam and they're like,
hold on,
let me check for mercury and let me
see what, how much arsenics in this.
So we kind of heavy metal party.
What sets up bpps that they're
worried about the come from?
What does the stuff they're worried about?
The comes from bottles. Plastic? Yeah.
[inaudible] or something like that. I wish
I knew what that meant. Guess they did,
they did their first results
from November. I don't
know what he's saying. Oh,
so this is their first,
uh,
their first actual pulling of the garbage,
you know,
listen man, even if it takes 10 years,
if they could figure out a way to,
to get rid of all that plastic and we
could figure out a way to not put that
plastic in the ocean and we can,
maybe,
what I really worry about almost as much
as this maybe even more, is overfishing.
When you realize how many different
ships are out there using giant nets and
just scooping everything they catch inside
that net and then just serving it to
us and we were like, who you want to get
Sushi? Yeah, Sushi sounds good. You know,
we're like so close. He's just
sounds good. It's ocean genocide.
I mean it's fucking chaotic.
Man. Did they don't have real,
I mean they don't have real control.
It's international waters.
People were just cut and nets and dropping
them to the bottom of the ocean and
the catching things all the time.
There's nets all over the place out there.
He would just release their nets.
They just litter.
But you're always,
you've been very conscious about like
what you eat and like sustainability a lot
lately,
right?
Well I think sustainability. Yeah,
I do think about that a lot. Um,
I don't know if I'm that conscious of it.
I'm definitely guilty of
not being sometimes hungry
dream the unconscious about
it. I wish I was more conscious
back cause I'm putting my faith.
It makes me all sad. Yeah. I'm more,
I'm more conscious about
what I eat and I am uh,
sustainability in terms of
like the quality of what I eat.
I'm more conscious about that. I should
be more conscious about sustainability,
but sometimes it feels like, what does
this, what are you showing me here?
Is that a crocodile? God
Damn it. What is a big, big
catch with an exclamation mark
is the name of the fish guy.
40 million views on youtube.
It's a net that's full of stuff.
Oh, they caught a net. Oh, this is, oh, a
net, right. This is a fishing boat. Yeah.
Oh Jesus. Yeah. Look at
that. Look how it works.
They just scoop up every fucking
thing that's in that ocean.
It's really amazing that they fee.
I mean, what a horrific place to be.
If you're a fish,
imagine if fish,
we're like super smart
and this is their demise.
I mean this is an insane net filled with
living creatures that were going to eat.
Not Bro. It's just tilapia. Relax.
God, you're kidding. So dramatic.
Look at that.
That's a crazy bundle of
these ocean creatures.
And how often does this happen? A
day. Is it all day? I bet it is.
I bet this is all day.
I bet this is all day for years
and years and years and years.
And I don't think they take time off. I
think they keep going and if they're not,
they're someone else's there too.
And I think this is happening.
As long as they can make money selling
fish and we're willing to buy fish.
It's kind of insane.
You think people ever feel bad about it?
If any of those people feel bad,
maybe it's
possible. They're not monsters, right?
If they're, they might develop, uh Oh,
that guy just stepped right on a fish
though. Yeah, they get desensitized.
I'm sure. Man. Anything like he
cared. Oh well this is crazy. I mean,
this is not a person's supposed to be
able to catch a fish or a two fish or
three fish and then you eat
it. Like this is chaos, man.
This is some crazy thing where you have
to make filet of fish sandwiches because
there's, you know, 320 million people
and a hundred of them, 100 million of,
we want junk food anytime they want it.
I mean,
I don't know if that went to filet a
fish or if that's a expensive fish.
I really have no idea. I'm just
talking shit. Don't listen to me. But,
and I also eat fish,
so I'm a hypocrite.
But it is kind of crazy when you watch
this video and I'm not, you know,
I, uh, I'm not opposed to eating fish,
but I'm just saying the reality
of what this is is, is crazy.
This is a crazy scene and to
not deny it's a crazy scene.
I'm still going to eat fish and I feel,
I feel awful about this.
It does slightly make me want Sushi.
I looking at this,
it's crazy. When I was a server,
like a big question question.
People always ask us at farm raised or
is it wild caught and like this is wild
caught versus farmers. I don't know
why it would make a giant difference.
It just seems like bad either way tell
no matter what for these organisms,
but they're delicious and
they're really good for you.
But how, how are they going to ensure
that there's gonna be some left?
That's what's crazy. Like the, the human
governments need to get together and go,
hey,
we can't kill the whole ocean because
that is possible if you keep going at the
pace that it's going now,
if you really stop and think about what
the ocean must have been like when you
hear about those, uh,
Japanese tuna fishermen,
like did you see Jiro Dreams of Sushi?
Remember when those gentlemen were at
the fish market and they were talking
about what it used to be like, I used
to be tuna everywhere, so much tuna.
Now it's like a small amount and you
got to check to see if it's good.
Like they're watching it
happening in real time.
If you go from that point where that guy
was talking about today and then go 50
years from now at the
same pace, like, yeah,
now you gotta be,
but it seems like that it wouldn't be
that hard to be more conscious about it.
Well, it the very least, they have to
take into consideration the fact that, uh,
they need to maybe develop some sort of
an international program to breed these
things, you know, to, to, to like they,
they've done that with yellow tail, the,
they have these like a
ocean sort of almost like a,
like corralled in area and
they're out in the ocean,
but they're only in this one trapped
area and they're feeding them, you know,
and occasionally they'd get out, like
they get those yellow tails in Hawaii,
there was a storm and the storm wreck
their little enclosure and they got out
and now they're everywhere. So all these,
uh, Hamachi grade, like Sushi grade,
yellow tails are swimming around all
over the place and they're breeding,
they getting bigger. Yes. It's
crazy. It's interesting. But,
but I was thinking when they
were telling me that, well,
so if that's what they did,
like maybe they should do that
and just keep releasing him.
Maybe we should be a program that all
the people who buy Sushi Fund into that
just takes a little piece of the Sushi
money and uses it to develop these
programs to make sure that these fucking
fish keep reading so you can have more
Sushi. I think people would pay extra
for that shit. Right. Then they lady,
then they would feel good helping out.
Yeah.
That's what I think we can leave this
next, next, next, next generation ever.
Real good possibility of like
making things work out better.
I really think that like
it's totally possible.
I think it's possible that the world's
just going to keep bad at getting better
and better and there's
going to be terrible things,
but it's going to keep getting better
and better and then we'll be able to come
to some kind of time in our future worth.
Seems like things have improved.
I agree with you. I think we're headed
towards a, a job, a new golden era,
new enlightenment because, and I
think a lot of times these, um,
things that we think are negative or
are kind of indicators of that because
these are things,
a lot of these negative things we
talk about were happening either way,
but now we're more aware of them and
people fight them and people, um,
are more upset about them and they're
more public because of things with social,
like social media.
And I think that's a positive,
not a negative that people aren't able
to pull the wool over your eyes as
easily.
Yeah.
I think what's really interesting about
this time was that you got so many
people that are able to communicate,
um,
whether it's yourself or Joey Diaz or Ari
Shaffir or Mark Marin or whoever these
people are that have these podcasts.
So many people have this
ability to communicate.
So many people have this ability
to, you know, you show the life,
you let you show your world
and like a different way.
And everybody gets to compare all
these different ways that people are
communicating.
And we could kind of like come to maybe
a better understanding of why we think
the way we think and which I think,
especially one of the reasons why
I'm so hell bent on having people be
reasonable and tried to talk to each
other so that I think that everybody could
learn something from
each other in this world,
whether you're left or right or in
the center or religious or atheist or
whatever, there's too many, too
much conflict. It's unnecessary.
There's too much of what people are,
aren't, that has nothing to do with you.
And you should be able to
talk about politics or even
religion and be completely
calm about it and not be angry and
not get emotional and child life.
But we're programmed to
think you're supposed to.
We're programmed to think that every
fucking conversation about something you
disagree with is supposed
to be this angry battle of,
of oneupsmanship. And I don't think
it has to be, I don't think it does.
No. I mean, um,
there's certain issues that
like where you're like, oh,
I don't want to argue over my,
like civil rights or things like
that. You know, you're like, yeah,
I don't want to be like,
oh, okay, well you, you do,
you don't think I'm a full person.
Okay, let's have a point. Counterpoint.
There's issues like that.
But I think now so many things get wrapped
up in politics that people do forget
to be civilized and do forget that we've
always disagreed and we've always had
different sides and that's what
made us a country, you know,
as the fact that we were the take the,
like you said,
the mix of those conversations and
that's the way that we kind of head in.
Yeah.
So where we find out who we really
are as opposed to who our side is,
painting the other side as
you know. And I feel like, um,
what I meant by people like being able
to get along is you can have opposing
thoughts and still be a nice person.
I want,
if you're like a really
super conservative person,
like sometimes I want to know why.
Like I don't want to oppose you
as much as I want to know why.
I want to know what you're
thinking. Like, what, what is,
what's pushing you in this direction?
What makes you think this as opposed to
if you are really progressive person,
what makes you think this?
Like what's going on like that that
conversation can be had in a way more
peaceful way?
Well,
maybe we could all examine why we
think about things a certain way.
And I've been thinking about a lot when
it comes to religions lately. This,
we're so fucking tense about religions,
so fucking tense lately.
And if it's not for like kids getting
abused or wars getting started over it,
the vast majority of it is just a
guideline for people to live their life.
And if you take that away from them or
tell them, then that's bad for them.
I tell them they can't live that way
then then you've created this conflict
that's really not your business.
Right. And a lot of ways, yeah,
I didn't think like that before.
I used to think before that, like,
that's not what I believe.
So you know, these people,
there must be something wrong
with the way they're thinking.
Mm. Well, that's a lot
of times that's what, um,
certain organized religions painted
as, right? Like if you aren't believe,
if you don't believe in that,
even you can have same
branch of Christianity or
whatever, but it's like, Oh,
if you're not Protestant,
sure you know this,
then you're not falling it completely.
Or,
and to me it was always so many of
these rules ended up just being like,
hey, be a nice person. Yeah, don't, don't
be a jerk. Don't murder people that,
you know, in there,
those are kind of costs.
And through all of those
things where you're like,
that's something I can take from you,
but to judge someone else's
life based off of their,
their sexual orientation or
something, a, of anything that,
that to me never dies, you
know? Right. So I'm always like,
I'm open to whatever you want,
whatever makes you not be a fucking jerk.
I'm four.
Yeah, no, I'm with you 100%.
I remember the first time I found out
there was other religions, like I want to,
I was raised a Catholic when I was a
little kid and I've found out there was
other things other than being a Catholic.
And I was like,
what are you talking about? So if
there's other things, cause uh,
my uncle was converting to Judaism and
so I was like, what does that mean? Oh,
he's going to become Jewish.
Like what does that mean?
Like what are you talking
about? I was like, you know,
five or something like that.
I was like, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute. You can shit.
There's different ones. Like what
do they think? Like who's right.
I remember being like six years old going,
shit,
there's more than one story that you have
to follow. We're not sure who's right.
And my uncle is going to
switch over to the other story.
Now he believes a different story.
I can't believe this.
He's got an adjusted story and you know,
you fall into this pattern,
now you're in this, this story's
pattern. Like, wow. You know,
we lost him to the Marvel Universe,
DC comics for so long.
He was all about Batman and Superman
and now he's like, fuck them.
I'm with the Avengers.
Crazy as a phone way look at it.
It's an interesting way of looking at
it without being disrespectful to either
side. It's like, wow, okay. You
know, I don't know who's right.
We know who makes better
movies. Yes. Yeah.
The choose do an excellent
job making movies.
It's amazing how much they've been
involved in show business. You know,
when I'm watching that marvelous Mrs
Maizel then make sure a realize like,
oh yeah, Lenny Bruce is Jewish. This
guy was Jewish doc. I was Jewish.
There were so many Jewish guys in
the early days of stand up. Yeah.
Got a little mafia, you
know, the same time,
there was a lot of Jewish
boxers back then too.
So thing that people
probably don't know it was,
they were a underclass and a lot
of ways or you know, um, and like,
that's like now it's Russians.
Like you get a lot of Russian boxers now.
[inaudible] ass, motherfucking Russians.
Tude hard men, hard man, because they're,
they're coming over here from a hard
place and they're fucking people up,
you know? And it's like one day
it'll be someone else. It's, it's,
it's interesting how it goes
in these waves, you know? Yeah.
But whatever country is not doing well.
Yeah.
And it's interesting when you see the
waves of standups come out of these
countries too, you know, like,
like there's different styles of standup
now in different parts of the world.
You know, standup is really a
global thing now. Like legitimate,
like an English guys have their own style.
You know, there's a lot of those guys,
like, I've never been to Edinburgh,
but, um, Ari Shaffir goes all the time.
He's like, dude, they have like, oh,
they'll do these hours on just a subject.
All the themes. Yeah, exactly. Different
Vibe, different style, a lot less.
Um,
rowdy Lollis I'm boisterous.
Just people listening. They're
great at listening. Uh, we did, um,
uh, Sweden and, uh, we,
we played Stockholm,
me and Tony Hinchcliffe and Tony
was like, dude, it's just like,
they didn't like me. I going
to know. They're just polite.
I go in between the jokes. They're
just quiet. They're listening,
you're not used to that. And
he's like, okay, okay. Okay.
And he went out the second one, he
was like, you're right, you're right.
They just so nice that something
was wrong. But it's, it's,
I'll put it in for your timing cause it
makes me to have to have more material
because you're used to like
waiting for a few seconds am great.
Well it's also, you know,
that's, it's, it's not,
I don't think it's that
common art form over there.
I don't think they have a long history
of having standup in Sweden do that.
Not that I'm aware of. I mean,
maybe they do and we don't know.
But for whatever it is,
it's,
it's diminutive in comparison to
any of the places that we know.
If they'd have scenes, whether
it's New York scene, you know,
La has seen San Francisco, there's like
some big scenes here where, you know,
funny guys who,
and girls who've come out of these scenes,
you don't hear like a lot of
guys from Sweden, do you know?
Yeah. But they're starting to get more
of them. There's getting more of them.
Everybody all around the world, they
started getting more comedy. It's really,
it's an interesting time and that way
it's very similar to Jujitsu. You know,
Jujitsu at one point in time there's
only a few places you get it outside of
Brazil. It was hard to find someone who's
really good at teaching it and now it's
everywhere. I was in New
Zealand and Australia, it's
an Africa, it's everywhere.
There's Jujitsu, old Canada and fucking
the Puerto Rico is Jujitsu everywhere.
All over the world. Cuba, everyone
has Jujitsu, you know, just spread it.
Found out it was awesome.
That could be the same with Stan
then in forms back into the practice,
right,
because there's
everybody's doing new style
hundred percent and everyone is like,
there's a really accelerated learning
growth from the time where it starts
getting put on the Internet,
which is like around like 95 96 and the
Internet kind of becomes alive from that
point on.
People comparing Jujitsu techniques
and watching matches and then you know,
new gyms opening up all around America
in particular. It's like the whole level,
the sport went through the roof.
It's crazy.
Yeah. I think, yeah, I think that's very
similar to comedy because I think a lot,
um,
my personal growth was I was able to do
it because I was able to watch so much
comedy and also I was able to get on the
Internet and read about a lot of comedy
and in Twitter and Youtube or Twitter was
just starting in Youtube was going and
I watch a lot of them
watching the videos with you,
would you invincea those things, you
know, and a lot of that stuff, um,
informed my comedy at an early,
early age about like making a style or
just how I wanted to write for myself.
Because when you're,
especially when you're first starting,
a lot of what will work
when you're first starting,
we'll set you up for failure later as far
as like pandering to people are riding
for these rowdy rooms. There
were bar rooms, you know, and,
and those things don't
work when you go to travel.
And so if I didn't have like the internet
or they always have these things too
wise to go like, oh, don't
worry about this time.
Don't worry about this local scene as
much because you don't want to be a local
act, you know? And that was,
that was very helpful for me. And
that's it.
Yeah. No for me too, man. I know exactly
what you're saying. Yeah. Well listen man,
let's wrap this bitch up.
Thank you for doing this.
Tell people where can they see
your special? Oh, they can get it.
It's called giggle fit. It's available
on Itunes, comedy central on demand.
Amazon, your x box, your playstation
anywhere really beautiful.
And your Twitter handle is at Ron Funches.
I have my podcasts getting better.
Instagram, Instagram, Ron Funche, ladies
and gentlemen. Ron Funches. Thank you,
sir. Appreciate your band. It
was fun. Appreciate you Joe. Bye.
Okay.
Hmm.